We live,
you just gave me a three.
There was no to those.
That was just a three.
I get,
I keep waiting for the to the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by.
If you go to a Rogan.ting.com,
it will explain what the fuck ting is
and it will also give you $50 off of any
of the smartphones that ting has in
their,
their lineup they have.
Um,
what ting is,
is like a non evil cell phone company
and what they're doing is they use the
sprint backbone.
You don't have to have a contract,
you cancel anytime you want.
It's,
there's a lot of great deals where you
can combine your minutes,
like you and your wife can share minutes
or something like that.
Or you and your husband or you and your
boyfriend.
If you're a guy.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is ting has some pretty
dope phones.
All the high end android phones,
you can get 50 bucks off of one of
those.
And the way they have it set up is they
use the same backbone that's apprentice.
Sprint is on,
so you're not on a mickey mouse
coverage,
you get like a,
like one of the top cell phone providers
in the country as far as like your
signal goes.
Joey Diaz swears by that sprints shit
dog.
That's all.
I have a goal with sprint to the end.
Um,
but it also has four g connections and
they also have great fonts like Brian
and I both have the Samsung Galaxy s
three and it's fucking sick.
It's a great phone.
It makes iphones look really stupid.
Like if you try to like,
look at pictures and go on the Internet
and it makes so much sense.
This sweet camera to.
It's a pretty,
pretty fucking dope phone.
They all,
they have ever pretty much everyone now.
I think they even have the note.
Yeah,
they have the note too.
So,
uh,
they,
they essentially have all of the high
end.
They have the note.
Yeah.
The Samsung Galaxy note to which is the
newest one.
I'm all the high end android devices.
They even have flip phones if you're a
fucking Weirdo and you want to get some
little shitty ass flip phone that
doesn't do anything and you get a text
with your thumbs if that's your shit,
Dana White,
just going to say this,
anti tend to that.
He's got a little flip phones.
But um,
if you're,
if you're into that,
they have that stupid shit as well,
but it's an excellent company.
It's an ethical company.
They provide you with an excellent
service and it's very reasonable prices
and they haven't set up that if you
don't use the minutes,
like if you say you're going to use a
certain amount,
you only use half of them,
they refund you money on your next bill.
I mean it's just a fucking great company
and that's why we,
uh,
that's what we do business with them.
We're also brought to you by
onnit.Rogan.ting.com
soccer.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com on ig.com.
That's o n n I t.
and if you've never been there,
Josh Barnett,
you should go because it's all shit that
you would be into.
It's manly shit.
Like we sell kettle bells and battle
ropes.
Okay.
Battle Bells.
We need to get those.
How do you see that?
They have.
Well,
we have a bunch of different fitness
shit.
We have um,
a medicine balls,
which I've just started using medicine
balls.
Right.
That's excellent.
You can put bengay on your nuts,
right?
That is a painful medicine.
Yeah.
Have you ever actually put Bengay and
your boss?
Have you ever done that?
Just for a recreational purpose.
I shaved my balls once and I put
aftershave on my balls to see what it
would feel like.
Oh my.
So you're getting a blow job to remind
her of her dad was a terrible mistake.
It was unbelievably painful.
I thought.
How painful could it be?
It's just,
you know,
skin like you look,
if you shave your face,
then you put after shave on,
you get the splash of light,
but it's okay.
I'm like,
how much worse could it be on my balls?
It's a lot worse.
It's exponentially worse.
So totally different experience.
Uh,
what shape did you.
Were you,
were you a Stetson man?
No,
I went with one of those black velvet.
Those blick or what did I put on my
face?
No spice old spice.
That's good.
Yeah.
That can go with.
I go with old spice deodorant.
Old Spice Guy.
Like old spice.
Did you do the home alone slap to your
balls afterwards?
No,
I squeeze them tight because they were
furious.
I grabbed them and squeeze them as if I
was somehow or another.
They're going to stop the pain by
squeezing my balls and I'm telling you,
you're just going to give a girl a
flashback or.
Oh my God,
it's Grandpa.
GRANDPA again.
Well,
you know the old spice on the COC.
Oh,
Jesus did not know where you're going
with that.
Just wherever I go with it,
it's always going to be bad.
Bad,
bad.
Josh Barnett.
I like the sound of this ting.
That sounds pretty awesome.
Although at first I thought it was like
someone's massive joke on like Asians
and cell phones.
Right.
That would be rude.
That would be rude as fuck.
No,
it's just a name.
What is t?
His is a Tang.
Does it mean anything?
What is it tingling.
Is it like a technical term or anything
like that?
Oh No,
like Ping Ping is if you send a packet
on the Internet,
so somewhere when it hits the next
server it sends you like the time and
that's a pain.
The server was important back in the
quake days.
Oh yeah.
You got a ping.
The server is checked to see what your
latency.
Yeah.
You want to be able to fuck people up
when they can't fuck you up and then
you.
But no matter what,
when you're losing,
you're doing shitty.
It's like,
Oh God damn it,
I fucking lag the lag.
Got Me.
Me.
Anyway,
on it.com
o n n I t we have a bunch of different
packages now,
or you can actually buy a kettle bells
and that,
uh,
excellent.
Uh,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout DVD
that I've talked about on the show.
Basically what happens a lot is the
we'll talk about shit on the show that I
really liked and we'll wind up just
selling it on it.
Just because it's awesome.
That's how it is with those Blendtec
blenders.
That's how it is with this,
uh,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout DVD.
It's a fucking phenomenal workout.
It's,
if you can get through that with a 50
pound kettle bell and you could do 45
minutes urine,
Anna,
45 minutes.
Fifty Pound Kettlebell.
Yeah.
It's brutal.
If you can do it,
you are a fucking the animal.
You're,
you're,
you're a serious one of those freak
crossfit motherfuckers that runs up
pills all day.
They're,
they're in the best in the world at
working out.
It's an incredible,
incredible.
A DVD.
It's in.
This guy's in like some serious shape.
The Guy who,
uh,
who,
what,
what the fuck is his name?
I don't remember how we used to start
talking about my other units.
Then hopefully Kelly units around the
podcast.
Why?
Why is that?
Because.
Oh,
I get it.
He can't sell Mila Kunis.
We can make not like that,
man.
I'm telling you.
She's not like that.
You don't know or you don't know.
Like,
I know I heard Ashton paid a pretty
penny for her.
What?
That's who she's dating now.
Aston Kutcher.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So shower with or $2 bills and the
dudes.
The dudes name is Keith Weber,
the guy who is the guy who takes you
through the workout in the extreme
kettlebell cardio workouts like
somebody's already.
Hey,
he's bad ass.
You would love him.
You love him.
He would love you.
He probably give you a neck rub anyway,
dot com.
Go get yourself some protein,
some Alpha brain,
all of the supplements.
Use the code named Brogan and you will
save 50 percent off.
What's No 10 percent off?
Jesus Christ.
Could you imagine?
What did I just say that for?
I was thinking of something Chris was
trying to do.
I was trying to think and talk at the
same time.
If you use a code name Brogan,
you save 10 percent off.
Okay,
and here's the other percent is if you
do not like Alpha brain or shroom tech
or are these supplements that you buy?
We have 100 percent money back
guarantee.
No one is trying to rip you off.
The stuff that we're selling is the best
shit we can possibly sell you.
I know I say this all the time and I
know it's annoying,
but on the hope that there's a new
person listening to this podcast,
unfortunately we all have to go through
the shit over and over and over again.
That's why I have a fast forward button.
Pitch it.
You don't have to listen to me,
but sometimes we'll say shit in the
middle of these commercials and it makes
it better than just a regular
commercial.
Okay?
Look what I.
Josh Barr now,
kettle bells out.
This motherfucker is prepared.
He's Karl gotch trained bitches.
He knows all about strength and
conditioning.
Use a code name Brogan.
Save yourself 10 percent off and by the
way,
yeah,
no one's trying to rip you off,
blah,
blah.
Hit The music bitches.
The Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
So many times we started this podcast
off and I never say who I'm talking to
him until about an hour in,
so I will just say it right up front.
A manly man,
a man of character,
a man's man who likes muscle cars and
fucking psycho music and it's an
intellectual dude,
a guy you sit down and talk to Josh
Barnett,
lives in channel,
bring her home.
I break bread and bring,
bring me on home to introduce me to mom,
tell her about raping and pillaging and
not necessarily,
but if you lived in another era,
you might be on the menu,
could be to make a good conquer.
If you came in on a boat and everybody
else was doing,
you would go out and do your thing.
You know it.
I will be at that and be like drunk fast
or you send them a bitch.
So,
uh,
what's new for you?
Man?
I know you're going to be in the end.
The last strikeforce card,
right?
Which is in January for folks that don't
know Josh,
Josh is a former UFC heavyweight
champion,
a king of pancrase.
How many other titles did you get?
Uh,
bunch of grappling titles,
grapping titles.
I think I had a,
a smoothest penis head.
If we were going to have a manliest men
board of approval,
I would have to have you on this
manliest men board of approval.
You're clearly about as manly as it
gets.
I think I appreciate it.
We can go to you and we can get like
real strict,
like no nonsense.
I saw you straightened up dudes nose
with a fucking pencil.
Got Video of it on the end of that dude,
guys,
those broken Josh like you want me to
fix it?
I'll fix it right now.
Faced with a fucking pencil,
shoves a pencil.
This dude's nodes and breaks it back and
you see it.
You'd see the crunching and see if he
can find it because it's pretty fun.
It's pretty fucking funny.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm there for,
for that boob jobs.
Pretty much any kind of general surgery.
Did he break his nose sparring?
Was it like,
did it actually with,
uh,
with,
he was doing snatches.
Oh,
the barbell.
And somehow he manages to waylay himself
right in the face.
He crushed it.
He nailed well,
he'd already mangled it.
Pretty good.
Uh,
uh,
doing rugby earlier on.
And,
uh,
I think in college maybe something like
that,
he'd been doing rugby for years,
so you'd already known the pleasures of
a broken nose,
but this was just out of nowhere.
So,
you know,
there's an interesting debate that's
going on right now,
uh,
amongst people that are football fans,
but that are also realizing how much
damage these players take and they're
trying to figure out what to do about
it.
And one of the more interesting ideas
that it's being presented is the idea to
make them wear leather helmets to take
away these big fucking hard helmets that
allow you to crash into each other full
speed and just give you a little
something that protects your skin.
And that's basically all you got.
And you can't have the same strategy can
go head to head like that.
You can't crash into each other,
no pants,
leather helmets.
And the idea is that if they,
if they rocked it down away,
we would avoid a lot of these crazy high
speed collision.
People would be more realistic about it.
I think it would cut down on the high
speed collisions.
Uh,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't have people blowing into
each other near as hard.
I've had the argument with people that
are big rugby fanatics for years that
I'm like,
look,
rugby guys don't hit as hard as football
players.
I mean,
it's not just that they have pads on us,
they're huge,
they're running fast and those,
you know,
the pads in addition help you to just
like lay everything you got into another
human being.
However,
I mean,
let's be honest,
look at these monsters.
I mean,
you stick them in leather,
they're still gonna start smashing into
each other.
I don't know if it's going to stop from
people getting as hurt as bad or
right.
But the problem is like the sports
already developed into what it is and to
try to take it a step back.
Things don't usually go a step back.
Do you want to watch guys in leather
helmet?
No.
Like patty cake and grab each other's
balls and there's a video that's being
played above your head.
Oh yeah.
Two bends in the states.
No,
it's just so gnarly.
But this is some known.
Don said,
Shit,
look,
he just opens a pathway.
I'd like to say that I was just looking
to see whatever I could find a Jamun
pianist,
his Schnoz anyways,
just for the hell of it,
but it actually makes sense.
Oh yeah,
it totally makes sense.
If you can get it to heal in the correct
position,
it won't be nearly as fucked up as if
the cartilage is all bent up in there to
get mine fixed.
I broke it when I was a little kid.
I fell down a flight of stairs my whole
life.
It was fucking nights were really the
only way to really do it if you have a
bad enough break,
is to,
uh,
to have like a,
an ear,
nose and throat doctor go in there and
do the proper stuff to it.
But it's,
it's a hellacious coming back from it.
I didn't think it was.
No.
Well,
I've heard,
I've heard of people like crying blood
out of their eyes and that's pretty cool
and a metal sense.
Save the buggers.
I'll show you some passive one.
Oh my God.
Let me show you something because you
can't even believe these are real.
I,
uh,
I showed one of my buddy Tom,
me and Tommy,
we were,
uh,
at the airport and I blew this fucking
booger into this tissue.
It did not look real.
It looked like it came from another
planet.
Blood clot fucking insane.
It was huge.
First of all.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've got the photos,
I've saved them.
I mean,
there was no way I was ever going to let
this go.
It's just going to take a few.
Um,
I have a lot of God damn pictures in
here.
I've got to go back to when it was,
which I think was about three years ago.
Oh,
that was,
it changed.
Oh,
that's my picture.
When I was back in the day,
I'd hit it.
I would do,
I would hit it.
And it's me trying to find these
buggers.
Ma'Am.
Something literally here couldn't.
You couldn't imagine this coming out of
a human being.
I've put this online,
I'm sure.
No,
I definitely did.
I put it on my twitter page.
So Brian,
if you could find it,
uh,
Joe Rogan's bloody snot on twitter.
I bet there's a photo of it up there.
As long as it stays up there.
I'm imagining some comic book villain of
a booger.
It's just unbelievable.
I mean,
I wouldn't be talking it up this much if
it wasn't really unbelievable.
But for ladies and gentlemen,
if you have a broken nose,
if you get the inside of the nose fucked
up,
if you,
if you know,
like,
I know like mayhem had thought about
getting his fix but he's still fighting.
So it's like I can't do it until I'm
done.
But if you get a chance,
that's the only one.
That's what it looks like.
A,
like cartilage and everybody's like,
just pieces is unbelievable.
And that was the only one that's not
even the biggest one.
I had some other ones that were even
bigger.
They were so ridiculous.
I blew them out and I looked at him in
my hand.
I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding.
How'd you feel if that thing came out
like a,
like a potato chip came out of my,
uh,
blood giant bloody Nacho.
That's what it was like.
Yeah.
There's a look at the size of that
fucking thing.
That thing came out of my note.
What did it tastes like?
Calgon take it wasn't good.
It something I would recommend you try
and um,
it was,
it was unbelievable.
I would,
I would shoot those out of my nose.
I'm like,
it leaves out here.
Here I was,
I got a bunch of pictures I really need
to,
to get my nose fixed.
I broke it a long time ago,
kid.
And then I broke it again.
Really a in this first round of that
super ball tournament and it just,
it bleeds easy now,
which is a problem.
So that they,
what do they do?
They cauterize the inside.
They've tried doing that.
But the way to get up,
I need a doc to get.
That's impressive.
That's unbelievable,
right?
I blew 100 of those three or four
months.
I hope you have that framed in your
house.
I should,
I should just stay in my office or at
least put it in one of those led,
rotating picture frames.
The dog,
the kid.
Fuck.
That's a great idea,
dude.
I might do that.
I'll do that and put one up in here.
That's what we'll do for the,
for the studio.
Um,
so,
uh,
you're on the last strike force card.
Yes.
Is it January
twelfth in the wonderful Oklahoma City?
Uh,
we'll be down there a beating the crap
out of each other for the last time
under the strikeforce banner.
But uh,
it'll be on showtime as usual so people
will be able to see it.
What did you say,
Tim Kennedy's pissed off.
He thinks that he was mad a little bit,
you know,
those,
uh,
high level military dudes,
they tend to be a little high strung on
edge.
Yeah.
But he was talking about how he thinks
of all these guys are pulling out
because it's the last card they just
don't want to fuck because it won't mean
enough to them.
They want to just try to get fights in
the UFC.
So they're just pulling out of the last
strikeforce.
I think that was what he was
insinuating.
He was definitely saying that
beyond the realm of possibility for me,
I look at it and people love to complain
about,
oh well you don't,
you don't,
you're not fighting this guy.
You're not fighting.
We're not fighting that fight.
I fight the people that they put in
front of me and,
and you know,
they're like,
well,
who the hell is this?
And slash or guy.
I'm like,
I don't fucking know and I don't fucking
care.
You know what I mean?
He's just another fucking victim that.
And no matter what,
if it was Nan door or junior dos Santos,
I get paid the same right now.
So I really don't give a shit.
I,
I fight who steps up and uh,
you know,
that's just the way that you're
fighting.
He is impressive looking.
I'll give him that.
He does look like he's a man door,
Gill Amino Guild Amino.
That doesn't sound Australian to me,
but whatever.
Is that where you're supposedly from?
That's where he's from.
He's called the Hun.
So I plan.
I can dig that.
The hunt fights for master.
That's pretty intense shit.
Yeah,
that sounds a like a like some sort of
fantasy movie.
He's,
it looks like a big giant end of the
world type dude.
He does.
He's got a nice big thick brow over his
eyes.
Well his tactics may strikes fucking
gigantic and it looks like actually
building.
Well they shot it up,
you know,
tricks of camera.
He's like six,
two,
2130.
So he's a pretty decent sized,
smaller size of the heavy I think.
Just think he likes to do a lot of
curls.
Okay.
And he's probably got the tiny legs.
Oh,
it's one of those dudes and he's
fighting in the UFC.
How's that possible?
Well,
maybe it's just a,
I don't know,
man,
but he's a,
he's got some fights under his belt.
He's not,
he's not like,
he's never been there before.
And he's 36.
He's,
he's gonna come in fit and I.
and he thinks this is his opportunity to
fuck somebody up and you think it's
going to be me.
So yeah,
it looks so that's a big step up for
that dude.
And you know
that happens man,
a lot in mma where guys that someone was
talking about Danny Lozan,
Joe Lowe's,
his brother first fight in UFC fight,
Spencer Fisher,
that's pretty big.
That happens.
That kind of shit happens.
This guy.
That's a giant opportunity for him.
But really he should like if you looked
at it like in the world of outside of
MMA,
if it was like a boxing thing,
that guy would have to go through a lot
more hoops and ladders before he gets to
a Josh Barnett level.
That's true.
And then the thing with boxing also is
that they,
they put their cars together based on
how they can promote it for the back end
dollar or two specific to the bouts
themselves were with him May.
It's just like,
Hey,
we have a card or on it.
Let's just have him fight.
Yeah.
Because a guy like this,
I mean obviously he's got,
he's got a few fights under his belt,
but you know,
you're a former champion,
you're a big name,
both in pride,
big name in strikeforce,
big name in the UFC.
Like that doesn't make any sense.
Like this is a guy that uh,
if you were banking,
you know,
if you see,
like if it was like Bob Arum,
something like this,
they will probably never scheduled like
this.
They go,
wait a minute,
we can make a lot of money.
I've charged Barnett.
We got to move them into a good position
to get them a big name fight.
There's very few big name guys,
especially outside of the UFC that at
this point there's only a few and you're
one of them,
you know,
and outside of you,
there's really not that many anymore,
you know,
now who else is left?
Just me now.
Cormier and a
and a fader is done.
He,
he says he,
he was,
he was going to retire.
He was,
he was thinking about it apparently at
one point in time.
Then he had a loss and his family.
And uh,
yeah,
I think he's a,
I believe he's retired.
I don't really see him coming back.
If he does,
it won't be for some time.
I just don't think that fighting is so
absolutely necessary to him.
I think he's,
he may be looking at different stages in
his life and I think from,
from how I know him anyways,
he seems pretty content with the things
that he's doing outside of fighting and
happy with family and church and things
like that.
Yeah,
he definitely doesn't have the same last
for it that he had.
Like when he fought cro cop,
like back in those days I,
I considered that like his prime,
like the one of the first cro cop fight
I think.
Uh,
he just,
he,
he went after him on the feet,
like he basically walked down like one
of the best kick boxers and mma.
Well that's the thing,
when you're fighting a good striker,
you,
you got a and,
and that fueled or wanted to.
Needed to put him on his back.
So he had to close that distance.
And the only way you can't just walk
into them,
you're going to get tagged up,
meaning he got cracked with a lot of
good shots.
He had yet to be aggressive.
You have to be quick coming forward and
then initiate those opportunities to put
them on his back.
You know,
every time I fought cro cop,
I came forward to.
Because again,
if I,
if I want to put them on the floor,
I can't do it backing up.
And everybody that backs up the more
distance you give a guy like cro cop,
especially back then,
the more he would look for is
opportunity to land kill shot,
then fucking left high kick or just a
middle kick or you know,
he was a hellacious low kicker too.
But uh,
uh,
he uh,
filter look great in his last couple of
bouts.
Looked real sharp,
but I think it was more just to prove to
himself that he could do it.
That,
you know,
all right,
well I have the ability and I can stay
in here and be a top guy.
But I've done this and I'm good.
And I guess his brother just recently
retired also,
and then uh,
um,
uh,
Tim Silvia is still out there and
around,
I don't know,
I mean he's got a pedigree and he has
still a pretty high high record of wins
versus losses and Arlovski is trying to
make a run back into the limelight as
far as being a top everywhere.
Well,
I lost.
He's actually doing really well.
He's uh,
he,
uh,
he actually just beat Tim Wright.
He beat Tim and then he was disqualified
because of an illegal soccer kick.
Yeah.
I have a weird rule.
It's a one.
Is that one FC?
Is that Matt?
Uh,
Matt Hume's old,
a pancreas pro pankration rules in
Washington and they had this open guard
a call things.
So it was like the,
I guess the deal was you,
you're not supposed to spend a long
time.
So I fought and washing.
Well,
let me explain it to people that don't
know what we're talking about for most
fights,
you can't kick a guy in the head when
he's down.
You can only kick the body and the legs.
But in pride and the old school days,
you could do anything.
You could stomp guys,
you could soccer,
kick them,
you could do anything.
And a lot of people miss that technique.
So there's open guard thing is where
they allow the kicks stops as well.
Uh,
maybe no stomps.
Maybe just kicks.
I believe it just kicks A.
I'd have to pencil long,
but uh,
um,
but once they call open guard,
then you're free to do,
you know,
I,
I believe it was taken from Valley Tudo
Japan or something similar way back in
the day,
but it was like if you're on your back,
guy can go ahead and come around.
And soccer kick at your head.
Is the idea that if you've rocked and
you're down,
is that when he would not,
when would he not let you?
Soccer of all fours I believe.
Okay.
So if you scratch like,
you've,
you're down,
you're hurt,
then you can't soccer kick guy.
Look,
then he would stop.
But if he went to his back,
that would be open guard and you can
talk.
Okay.
That's interesting.
So only when the guy's on his back,
because I guess the idea is that your
legs and your hands are up in front of
you,
so you're protecting yourself.
That totally.
That actually is very logical.
The Japanese had a lot of very logical,
uh,
approaches to mma.
One of them that I really liked was that
10 minute first round.
Yes.
That's a brutal fight.
That really separated the men from the
boys.
Did that round was the endurance
breaker.
I liked it.
I loved that you go out there and you
just get it on some.
Yeah.
You,
you have to strategize your wind and
your endurance.
Uh,
but it,
I mean,
we didn't stop a lot of us from still
just going nonstop,
10 minutes,
man.
We'd just go for it.
And uh,
uh,
coming from a guy like me who started in
the days of no time limits,
I mean,
right.
And well,
you know,
for a guy like you also,
it's sometimes you would work for a
while to get a takedown and you finally
get to take down.
You only got 20 seconds left than
around.
The guy can defend.
But if there's five minutes and 20
seconds,
he's fucked right now and get a lot of
work in on a guy and five slash 12 that
really favor.
I mean that was one of the main
arguments for not having three minute
rounds in the first place is that you
wanted to give the grappler sometime to
work once he completed the tank down.
Right.
But if you look at like,
like consider the exertion that they put
off in a boxing rounds,
boxing the high level of boxing runs,
it's really not even nearly as
devastating as a high level MMA right
now.
It's different because you don't have
that muscle fatigue from constant wear
and and resistance and it's a different
sort of conditioning.
Or you can take a guy who's an excellent
wrestler who's got fantastic when,
when it comes to to contact and,
and,
and resistance and strength and balance
that way against another opponent.
But you get out there and you start
putting all these punches together and
all of a sudden his wind is gone,
got blasted because it's a different.
It's more akin to more of an aerobic.
Anaerobic just wind based,
then it's a different.
It's completely different.
Yeah.
It's interesting how it doesn't apply,
like fitness does not apply across the
board.
No,
no,
no.
And that's the thing is that the
Olympic,
uh,
the Olympic committees have done all
these,
uh,
these studies like committees,
whatever,
the,
uh,
all the people that come with all the
science and the training behind these
Olympic athletes and that is,
you can do sports specific training.
You can go ahead and shoot doubles with
bands on,
you can punch with dumbbells,
you can do all this stuff to try and
simulate doing your sport,
but in the end,
the only thing that makes you better at
your sport and the most,
especially in terms of endurance and
everything else is to actually do your
sport.
But because your body learns how to
relax,
it has muscle memory.
It has a um,
um,
your,
your brain understands all the movements
and dynamics of exactly what you're
doing and that's how it learns to be as
most efficient as possible in your
sport.
Yeah.
And so it's great.
You know,
all these strength conditioning guys
have come out of the woodwork,
especially I love all the guys that have
no fight training or fights under their
belt and they want to go and they train
all these fighters with all this stuff.
They see a Jim Jones or crossfit or a
now westside barbell and these are all
great systems that have amazing things
to take from it,
but I could have the best workout in the
world,
but it might not be the best workout for
this particular type of athlete and not
to mention he can do the best work out
in the world all day long.
If his time in the sport that he's
actually doing is not being applied,
then it's a waste.
You're not,
you're not going to really be able to
make the most of it.
You feel like there's a certain level of
the game were strengthened.
Condition is absolutely necessary.
We can get to like a rory macdonald
athlete level,
like absolutely.
You know,
I mean this kid at 23,
24,
something like that.
He's young,
he's a freakish and,
and he's so fucking athletic and he's
doing these incredible strength and
conditioning workouts along with all his
sports specific shit.
It's,
I feel like I absolutely agree with you
that the most important thing is
technique and efficiency and training
and sparring and timing and Mitt work
and all that good stuff.
But there's also,
you get to a Roy Mcdonald level where
he's got Roy Mcdonald.
He has that as well.
You know,
he's got all the training all the time,
putting in,
in all the intensity and the drills.
But then he also has this
and that's,
that was I actually,
I,
uh,
unofficially named that laugh that UFC
on Fox a card I called the UFC on Fox
five speed kills.
Basically everybody who is faster,
more conditioned and quicker beat their
opponents.
Well really what it came down to,
you know,
a Benson,
a Rory Gustafson,
all of them were quicker.
They were quicker to the punch,
they were better.
They seem to be better condition.
They,
they pushed the pace higher and they
beat all their opponents.
I mean,
they had great skillsets and great game
plans,
but they moved so much,
so much and had so much more speed over
their opponents that they just couldn't
keep up.
And uh,
um,
the athleticism,
strength conditioning,
that's a huge equalizer,
called God's Lord say technique within
strength.
If you're not strong enough and physical
enough to pull off a ship and you're
trying to do,
then it ain't gonna work,
you know?
And
that's such an important point because
that's sort of denied in the Jiu Jitsu
community a little bit.
You know,
there's a lot of people say I'm wearing
it,
by the way,
this is no disrespect.
And I got to Leo Gracie tee shirt on
right now when I'm saying this and work
requires a lot of strength and I've
trained with all the,
with a lot of top,
high level Jujitsu guys are legends like
Henzel Gracie.
I've rolled with these dudes.
And even as a kid I remember hearing all
the rhetoric about Jujitsu and the
gentle way and all this and you know,
no energy and effortless.
And I'm like,
fuck that.
These dudes are strong as shit.
They do everything with a huge amount of
strength.
They have a lot of technique,
but the difference like the difference
between like this Hen i Henzel and this
is back in Abu Dhabi and this other
fucking,
you know,
black belt champion Schmo from Brazil is
that black belt Schmo from Brazil does
the same move.
The hanzo does,
but it handles like fucking three times
as strong as that dude.
Right?
And he's going after it wrestling style
as well.
He's like snapping your head down and
clamping down on a guillotine and
yanking on it and put this mist on you
and you're trying to get your hand away
and you can't.
I tell them I'm a lifelong of grappling
strength today.
No question.
Perfect technique,
no question,
but absolutely strong given,
given a,
an uneven playing field are given,
even techniques,
you know,
even on the technique side of the person
who is stronger and faster is going to
apply it better.
Yeah.
You know,
I always had this theory about Hickson
and uh,
one of the theories about Hixon that I
always say,
if people know Hixon Gracie,
it was always considered to be the
greatest of the Gracie clan,
just like a magician on them.
Yeah.
But also like weight way more built.
I mean if you compare him to like,
well he is raising a physical specimen,
especially when he was young.
I mean he was just like a perfect
athlete,
but if you,
if you think about him when those days
he got more taps in because he was
stronger and he was like physically he
was a freak.
Like he was a great Yogi.
He's like a,
like a really an avid yoga practitioner
that belly flexibility,
strength and body control.
Mind watching them go at it with people
go hard fast.
Those clips from those Samo tournaments,
he just sign onto people's limbs.
I mean,
there ain't nothing like smooth
whatever,
like just chilling out and catching an
oh my friend y'all.
How are y'all?
No,
the guy's like,
oh,
he's like a,
he's like a fucking blast beat,
you know,
from a death metal song.
Just chewing through somebody's body.
I love that a guy like that exists.
I love that there's a guy that is the
one guy that stands above everyone else.
You know what I've always heard,
not to create rumors and not to say that
any of the people a fore mentioned ever
said as such either because,
uh,
you know,
they've never with this guy,
wouldn't you never ever,
ever,
ever talk shit or,
or try to like,
you know,
run around and,
and,
you know,
behind the scenes I'd be like,
oh,
but really he's not that kind of guy,
but I've always heard that from people
that have trained with both of them,
that Laborio is considered even better.
You know what?
That's a very funny thing that you said
that I was going to say Laborio is the
other guy that has that sort of Laborio
is like the most approachable,
friendliest,
sweetest guy.
She'll do it.
And laboriel even say about,
he'll talk about his competition.
He goes,
you know,
I just wasn't able to do as much in
competition as I had wanted to or as I
was capable of on the mats.
I mean,
he's not,
he's a humble,
straightforward,
no nonsense,
just a,
he's not a,
he's not going to bullshit about any of
it.
He's not going to sit back and start
naming off all these excuses or
whatever.
He goes,
ah,
you know,
that day I just,
I wasn't able to.
I know,
I'm like,
I should have taken that guy out and
like a minute.
But uh,
for whatever reason that it just didn't
work out,
maybe my head or this or whatever.
I mean,
he does.
He's not a,
he's not a,
some cocky sort of dude trying to make,
give himself an out to why he didn't
perform as what he wanted.
But that's one of the reasons why I
liked that guy so much because I know
how good he is.
I even watching them back in the day and
I'd tell him,
Oh man,
that was a really good match.
I mean,
he was like,
yeah,
you know,
it was cool.
It was all right.
But uh,
but you know,
I'd heard from all from these other
Jujitsu guys,
like,
man laborio actually,
that's the dude and people don't talk
about it,
but that's the guy that they think is
Charles.
Charles Mccarthy was the first person to
told me that,
but chainsaw.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
he told me a long time ago and then I
started asking around,
you know,
I was only like a blue belt purple belt,
but I didn't really know who the great
guys were.
But he said the other guy that was like
that with him that people don't give
enough credit to,
he said was travis Luder.
He said,
Travis Luder is a lot better than people
gave him credit for.
He's like,
he never really got his shit together
like conditioning wise and had a few.
Travis is tough.
We all knew that.
He was a pretty,
pretty talented when it came to,
uh,
to,
to his grappling skills on the mat.
I mean,
he very underrated.
He was Terry,
let's be honest.
He put Anderson on his back and did what
he wanted.
He just moved.
Yeah.
Let me tell you something.
The day before travis looked like a dead
man.
I mean,
I've.
I've never seen a guy in all my years of
being at the weigh ins and that's over
12 years now.
More than that,
if you count the nineties,
he was dead dude.
He shuffled to the scale for his second
attempt,
like literally couldn't lift his feet
up.
The chores were married up there.
Huh?
Looked horrible.
I've never seen a guy who his lips were
cracked and dried out like he had sucked
himself dry like a sponge.
He was still more than a pound over.
He couldn't make it.
He couldn't make the way.
I don't remember what the final thing
was,
but he just fits right.
Whatever happened,
it wasn't fucked up.
He wasn't a title fight and he was
dominating him,
but he ran out of juice.
I'm sure most of it was due to even
because he pooped out in mountain was
physical exertion and his muscles just.
They didn't have enough energy to power
them.
They didn't have any electrolytes.
You didn't have a mineral is needed to
keep those things going and they just,
they just gave up.
That one drives me crazy.
There's a lot of guys that I've seen
fall apart.
Honestly.
It hadn't been so exhausted and you
know,
that's,
that's up to look at saluter,
you know what I mean?
And his coaches.
But yeah,
I think he probably would have tapped
into
luder luder in top form in that fight.
Alluded that was not sick.
Would it get in the Anderson Silva a lot
of problems.
I mean Anderson is a lot better on the
ground and people think,
yes,
he's very wily.
Luder is so his more similar to like a
another guy that people don't
understand,
like a Picasso who tapped Anderson from
amount,
amount of triangle,
the uh,
I think it ended up being mounted,
but I started off on the back,
but a part of the reason why he,
I believe he tap Anderson and,
and,
and you can see that backstage footage
from pride and Anderson is so upset
about it,
I think.
And I know in my opinion why he's so
upset that he lost,
wasn't he?
Because he can't believe he got caught
like that is because what he didn't
understand is to.
Casa is one of those dudes that has
freak strength,
like unreal crazy,
like his arm feels like a pile of steel
strength when he gets a hold of you.
And I rolled with the dude and the guy.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe how strong this guy.
And I remember when Vernon,
Vernon,
White Russell.
Then back in Abu Dhabi,
it's like,
man,
that guy's a fricken stronger and you
think he is.
Then we're dudes like that,
right?
Yeah.
He's just crazy.
Fricking strong.
And so I'm guessing Anderson,
you know,
ended up on the ground,
he's like,
cool,
whatever.
And all of a sudden it's like,
holy fuck,
I can't get away shit.
And I think luder probably has some of
that similar quality of being a lot
stronger than people really understand.
I always liked travis from the get
because he was.
He came from the,
from the Jujitsu background,
but everyone's like,
he's a,
he likes lego blocks exit and he trained
at the lines and dudes and always been a
nice humble dude.
I've always dug travis,
speaking of leg locks for,
for folks who don't know,
for the longest time Jujitsu guys didn't
go for leg locks because they thought
that leg locks were who were cheating a
weak way to tap a guy.
And one of the,
I don't know what,
what,
what put that in their heads because
it's like a train.
Maybe you know why it's like,
let's just be honest,
they said that because they didn't train
it.
Um,
most of the training that was coming
down throughout the rest of the Jujitsu
tree was not including leg lots.
A lake lots are not really given a lot
of precedent even if they were illegal.
So they just ignored what made you
choose to do good in the first place was
adapting.
Sure.
And they just,
they,
because they weren't good at that.
Instead of accepting it and being like,
okay,
this is a weakness,
they just threw a fit about it,
wasn't it?
Also because dudes are getting fucked
up,
especially like heel hooks maybe,
I don't know.
I mean,
you don't have much time to tap how many
times,
especially people get their arms busted
off.
It's true,
but he'll hook seem to be even more
devastating.
It seems to me that you can snap your
arm back and get it repaired better than
you can fuck your knee sideways
potentially.
I think maybe the difference between,
uh,
the uh,
vertical like type of a break versus
that twisting.
Like if you had an arm and you twisted
it and smashed and tore up all the
tendons instead of just going one
direction.
Maybe that's part of the problem.
But also,
uh,
I think there's a bit of a disconnect
for people between their legs and their
arms.
Like they don't,
they,
they are more aware of their arm
position and how bad something is or
isn't versus their legs.
And then I'm sure some of that comes to
the lack of training.
Eric won a Pan Am games that blue belt
and blue belt,
purple something back in the day,
way back in the day back when,
you know,
he probably road there in a horse and
carriage.
And uh,
he tapped a bunch of people with leg
locks and the whole crowd booed him.
Isn't that crazy?
Ooh,
why I'm bringing this up is that it
changed somewhere along the line they
had to give up and they all go after leg
locks.
I mean,
it's the most,
it's most hypocritical.
Juarez is excellent.
He's the best.
He's just one of the scariest guys when
it comes to leg locks because he's a
fucking ridiculously strong dude and
he's got good technique.
So if he wraps a hold of that thing,
like you're in a fucking terrible
situation.
Yeah.
He's like a,
he's like a,
a,
like a Solomon Grundy of it may just
getting in there and just trying to
figure leg off.
And.
And your,
your best friend Hector Lombard went out
it.
Oh yeah.
Actually,
you know who's not bad at leg locks.
Hector Hector's very good at language
factors.
Good at actually hector's pretty good at
everything.
He will only choose to use a piece of
his arsenal for the most part.
I think that's more of a mental thing
than anything else.
But hector actually has a ton of tools
at his disposal.
Yeah,
we're very underrated ground game.
If you watch that leg lock,
there's a video of him competing,
uh,
one of the Nogi grappling tournaments
and he slaps a straight ankle lock in
this guy and breaks his leg and you hear
crack,
you know,
and like you see that torque that he's
put in with that
fireplug man,
we were talking about muscle ups.
How do you do muscle?
And Hector come eight man wasn't muscle
up man.
I'm like,
well what you do did you do like this?
And he goes like this man,
it also explained a muscle muscle up is
you grab a pull up bar and so you go and
you go through the whole pull up motion
of pulling yourself chin over the bar.
But once you get up to that point,
you pull your body all the way over the
top of the bar.
So now you're,
you're a,
a,
the bar is now at your waist and your,
you've got your arms completely extended
out.
It's ridiculously difficult.
Hard thing to do.
And,
and hector wasn't doing it like kicking
his feet like a crazy fuck.
He was just like,
like George of the jungle fucking
flinging himself around like this man.
Yeah,
like that.
You know,
you didn't have to do 12 of them to
prove it,
but you got to be 12.
It's something like,
he just fucking popped him out and he
goes,
I do pull up all the time map mode,
the digital,
the digital.
Jesus Christ got that crazy judo
strength.
He's got crazy.
Everything is crazy.
Genetics.
Crazy mentality.
Yeah.
Well it's.
When it works,
it's fantastic.
You know,
he's an exciting guy to watch,
man.
That dude,
he's got some fucking freak power in his
hands too.
He can hit.
He's fast.
He's very sharp.
He's a,
he's more of a,
he's not a heavy puncher.
And like that heavy flooding.
He's a,
he's a snapper.
Yeah.
Throws his hips into things.
You know.
That's one thing about judo guys as well
as a wrestler guys,
once they learn,
like especially a wrestler has got a
good power double once they learn how to
put that same effort and energy into a
punch like you saw with Erin Simpson,
Erin Simpson started putting people
away,
learn to spring into his punches.
You know,
once those guys really learn how to do
that.
Like Henderson,
Rashad Evans,
Rashad Evans has gotten ridiculous right
hand.
Rashad has tons more,
tons and tons of power.
Uh,
I think it's.
Timing is terrible though.
Yeah.
He often whiffs tons of punches were I
think he's throwing without thinking
instead of setting up that strike that
he's looking for instead,
I think you don't think he's getting
better at that now.
I'm sure there's improvement,
but I still think that that is like,
he doesn't lack speed at all super fast.
He doesn't lack power.
Uh,
I've,
I remember watching the chuck flight
gets going,
man,
he's getting tore apart in terms of
timing,
but chuck's hands are so down that and
that,
that right handy,
that right hook.
He keeps throwing his,
got knockout all over,
like you don't want to get touched by
that.
And boom,
he gets beat Clemson with it and chuck
goes out like a light or even he got on
top of forest and he threw just a punch
from down on top,
but it had such snap on it.
Boom,
tort a forest was out from there that
were shot of the chunk of Delphi.
There were shot that you saw against.
Um,
uh,
who's this last fight?
Well,
Jones,
but I wouldn't even know in his last
fight
are any fight.
Um,
Mr.
Wonderful.
Denise.
Oh he did.
But even still they're like,
I don't,
he's still not,
he's not really a timing's better,
but he still like,
there's so many opportunities that I
think he's a,
in terms of lining up good solid shots
and uh,
and putting his opponents away.
I still don't think he has as much
comfort and I'm just like,
he's not as at home on his feet as a
striker,
still as,
as perhaps as he could be.
Well,
he's been training with spong now,
you know,
those guys that done at the Blackzilians
with spong and with that Henry,
who's that guy,
I'm sure those guys put them through pad
work and all the different because they
Davis Friday.
I thought that was like some of his best
striking one of his best fight.
I just think what it comes down to is
it's not even necessarily the,
uh,
the,
the pad work he's doing or the technical
work or even just the flat out sparring.
I think it has to be a very engineered
drilling scenario to try and awakened
that potential in somebody.
A lot of times people they think,
well,
I need to get better on my feet so I'm
just going to spar more and spar harder.
But actually what happens is,
is it's a,
it's like the difference between doing
shoulders and doing your rotator cuffs
when you're doing your shoulders.
Like every muscle group comes into play
and often you know,
things like the rotator cuffs,
the weakest link,
you're not going to really draw upon
that because that's not made for
shoving,
you know,
weight,
overhead,
big heavyweight.
And and high stress loads,
so all of this other stuff is going to
compensate for your little muscles so
they don't have to work nearly as hard
when you've got these big movers in
place,
well,
when you need to work your rotator
cuffs,
you have to use a small way on purpose
because you have to try and get all this
to shut down so that it doesn't come
into play and you can work just those
little tiny muscles that often get over
overlooked and over compensated by the
bigger muscle groups and that's how you
work your rotator cuffs and you don't
doing small weight because you're a
pussy.
If you got to do small weight because
otherwise you're not going to engage.
Those muscles and other muscles are
going to come in and take over,
which you don't want.
You're trying to work on something very
specific.
Same thing with standup work.
You can't go out there and just go
harder and go fast and go tougher.
Sometimes you've got to really dial that
shit way the hell back way slower and
just start putting yourself in two
different mindsets and start putting
yourself into a position where,
okay,
well,
what am I working on here?
I'm always retreating too much.
Like so maybe you cut up like a little
square and you've got to stay within it
and you got to move slow and light and
just get used to getting hit and then
rolling with the punches and you're
slipping and your,
your head movement and because often you
know,
okay,
I'm going to work on my defense this
round and you're going hard.
You just get your head harder one
direction or the other.
Dip harder,
swing faster,
but you don't what?
You don't realize that you're actually
overcompensating your technique by your
athleticism.
Yes.
And uh,
what you have to do,
if you really want to work your
technique,
you got to scale it way the fuck back.
You gotta you gotta train the mind,
the eyes and the body all at the same
time.
And it's different
in this approach.
Your approach is one of the reasons why
you're this many years in the game.
Now.
I said I saw you fight way back in super
raw,
which was in the nineties,
right when,
right.
You're going to make 99.
Well,
I started my career in like a 96,
97,
but this,
this approach to it,
this cerebral approach did this the only
way you stay this lucid but this many
years in the fight game.
But this is the only way,
right?
I mean
much that uh,
and uh,
you know,
fucking people up bad so they can't
really do.
But uh,
back at Amc we used to do a lot of
flowing drills and things just weren't
all about killing each other.
I mean we had a lot of time killing each
other to trust me there.
Fuck,
you have to have both.
Yeah.
I mean,
we,
we have a good balance and the problem
with especially like,
so I've got this reputation of not being
able to keep sparring partners and all
this stuff,
you know,
because the problem is they come in
during fight training and they get
fucked up and I don't go to injure
anybody,
but you're damn right.
I beat him up.
So are you,
when you're doing flight training,
are you going full clip every sparring
session?
Do you go 70 percent?
Well,
usually 80 to 80 to 90
now.
Isn't that a.
it's a,
it's a fascinating thing.
The idea of how to correctly prepare
someone for an mma fight and with you
it's got to be really difficult because
it's probably not a lot of dudes.
You're going to take advice from that
know more than you at this stage of the
game.
So when you're piecing together your
training programs,
you're piecing together your stand up
and you're grappling and how do you,
how do you decide like how much time you
should put on this and how do you
engineer it?
It's a balance.
You have to be very honest with yourself
on what's necessary and you can't just
sit back and have this pride and ego
step over what what is important towards
developing you're training and I've got
guys like Eric Paulson and there's
Paulson is a walking,
talking encyclopedia,
fucking people up and.
But he also has the tendency to just
start pulling from everywhere sometimes
and so he'll throw in these techniques.
I'm like,
Dude,
one,
I've never even done that in too.
That's.
I don't fucking really think that's
applicable,
but that's just how Paulson is.
He'll hit you,
you know,
you say,
all right,
let's do a,
let's work on some hand combos and he'll
throw a thousand of them that you.
And.
But the thing is,
is that there is tons of valuable
information and tweaks.
It can be made.
You have to be smart enough and open
enough and,
and,
and present enough in this type of
training to work with him to develop all
those skills.
I mean,
I have all kinds of tricks that I've
picked up from Paulson over the years
that are.
I know it wouldn't have gotten any place
else because people don't have that kind
of background martial background and
even,
uh,
you know,
I've got specific coaches that what I do
is when I go on a train with them,
I really narrow it all down and I do
exactly what I'm there to do with them
and then when I'm done with it,
then I have to assess all the data that
I got from that training session and how
that's going to apply to me in the ring
with my overall strategy,
what works best,
where my natural tendencies are,
are,
and under certain scenarios and just in
general and uh,
and how to best incorporate it.
If I'll go and I'll do a training
session.
Often I'll have a hill.
My coach Nixonian will have me doing
these six seven punchkick combos or
involve me spinning and hook kicking and
all this kind of stuff.
I'm never probably going to be able to
pull that off.
Uh,
in the ring.
You know,
that whole start to finish at the top of
the double kicks up top boom,
spend bank,
come back,
boom,
boom.
Like,
but there are pieces that I could take
from that and use it in a combination or
use a setup to something else or set up
to a take down or is it counter?
Uh,
also just the ability to be more
dexterous,
more able,
more agile and just have better body
control and balance.
Uh,
yeah.
That's why GSP has been doing
gymnastics.
It's fantastic.
If I wasn't a big son of a bitch who
thinks their arms just pull off,
I tried to do it.
Not to mention who's a deteriorated his
body with years and years of training
and whores and alcohol.
Uh,
it,
maybe I would do more in gymnastics
other than bedroom.
Gymnastics.
Yeah.
My leg doesn't go there.
You shouldn't try either.
You can't even do rubber guard pulling
any kind of ironic.
Not really a
so don't know the,
you're,
you're a leg lock master.
You've known for your leg locks but it
needs are all fucked.
Oh yeah.
I mean knees,
ankles,
all.
I mean everything takes the price.
But uh,
um,
no,
I can't do rubber guard especially.
I'm just not,
don't have that kind of flexibility that
way.
And,
but uh,
I understand how it works,
you know,
I mean I can do pieces of it and I can,
I can get down there with someone like
Victor Webster or a,
a role for any of those dudes from 10th
planet and go,
okay,
well while you're working this,
your angle is off here.
You need to apply your pressure.
There you this,
that,
you know,
whatever.
And you know,
I'll do stuff if I'm at Eddie's just
rolling with vic and those dudes.
I'll throw rubber guard type shit on
Vic.
Best,
my best approximation and sometimes I
come up with some pretty clever stuff.
Somebody asked me,
why are all these fighters getting
injured?
Wow.
These fighters getting engine pulling
out of fights.
I'm like,
because they're doing a sport where the
whole key to the sport,
the,
the end game is breaking people's bodies
and then the practicing it all the time.
Sure.
How do you intelligently approach it's.
So you get through all the training but
with as little injury to your body as
possible.
Do you engineer that or you just roll
the dice?
I mean,
I think it's a little of both.
there's a lot of a factors that you just
can't account for,
you know,
somebody,
excuse me,
somebody just rolls into your leg,
whatever.
Nuts that's been coming up a lot lately.
And Dana talked about it that Rashad
Evans had to pull out of a fight.
The actual fight where Shogun lost the
title to Jon Jones shot was supposed to
fight Shogun,
but Diego Sanchez was wrestling with
some dude and accidentally see that
that's just a lot easier.
That's near each other.
No they shouldn't.
And,
and one thing that I got from Japan and
just always made total sense to me at,
uh,
at AACC A,
our bay and we were going to be Fuji is
Jim.
The other people that aren't wrestling
stand in between all the other folks and
keep them from running into each other.
We do that attend planet 10 flat does
that happened to.
And that's a,
that's a nice thing if you could just
come on,
you got to be smart with your training.
And sometimes like,
hey look,
look at this fighter.
He is completely beat down.
Wore out and,
and he's,
you know,
yeah,
you can try and get him to mentally push
through all this kind of stuff,
but guess what?
That muscle fatigue is there and he's,
he's right to be injured right now to
change training.
Yeah,
change your training.
That's where intelligence comes in and
that's what people don't understand
about mma is that,
you know,
I've,
I've had people like write these really
stupid things that are just knee jerk
reaction.
Oh,
these brain dead knee jerk reactions to
stuff.
I bet you've seen this,
you've seen this amongst people,
but when you really break it down in,
in order to really be at a high level
and compete in mma,
you are managing a lot of shit mentally,
emotionally,
physically,
and on top of that,
you're trying to piece together the game
with the most consequences of any other
game that the game of fucking people up
or getting fucked up.
There's the most consequences
emotionally.
Most consequences physically.
Anybody who thinks losing a basketball
game as hard as you could go out.
They're in,
you know,
going out and as a team losing,
uh,
let's say the NBA championships sucks,
you know what I mean,
but it really is only a real
motherfucker if you have the game
winning shot and you were actually
inside the,
uh,
the key and you throw it up and you blew
it.
Now that is way that's really painful.
That flows,
that's as close as you can get.
That kind of thing to being a fighter
and losing a major fight on national,
worldwide television.
That's.
And even still,
it has to be the championship.
You have to lose the APP,
that entire championship to do that.
And here's the,
the thing that also why it doesn't quite
get to that point for,
for that per,
that basketball player versus the
fighter because next year you get
another chance to just do it all over
again.
And while you may have blown it and the
whole city is like,
fuck you,
you suck,
whatever,
blah,
blah.
No one kicked your ass at the.
So.
So now you go and you compound the fact
that not only did you just do something
you had at all the cards,
you had all everything in front of you
and this was your chance.
Not only did you blow it in front of
everyone,
but somebody beat your ass to make you
blow it.
You didn't just go out there and fuck
up.
No,
you got fucked up and you lost.
You have the mental management
of all these different things.
The physical task of actually fighting,
controlling your energy,
knowing how to pace yourself on top of
knowing what to execute and there's so
many dimensions to execution as opposed
to like a standard,
like a basketball game or a boxing
match.
The dimensions.
I have so many messages,
fourth dimension,
like my third eye,
my brown eye.
When you're adding in,
I mean like how many?
Look,
I've watched a cro cop today versus
random and we were watching best of
pride.
I was going off on twitter,
did the fucking best of pride today was
insane.
It was a Dan Henderson's a second fight
with vandelay,
which is like one of the greatest fights
of all time.
That was awesome.
And then they showed cro cop getting
knocked out by random in and I was like,
man,
that is where that wrestling dimension
really falls into place because cro cop
is so worried about that takedown that
he gets clipped with a big punch right
where he probably would not have gotten
clip with that.
It was just a standard standup.
Like exactly.
It just makes it all so random or
engaging the fake.
And then he came up with new.
The kick was coming.
That's when he threw the punch.
There's so much intelligence and
strategy and consequence and it's like
it's,
it's such a highly charged game that
when people like say things about it,
like a bunch of braindead Mongoloid is
beating the shit out of each other.
It's just like sand some.
But it's such a silly point of view.
It is.
It says that it's just
anytime,
like I read something,
uh,
and this,
this really got to me.
There was a,
an article on,
there's this new thing on vice called
fight land.
Yes.
And one of the guys on there,
uh,
likes to interview musicians about what
were their fight music b,
and he interviewed some guy that's like
a producer or something and the guy just
essentially just spewed vitriol about
how stupid fighting isn't fighting is
dumb and that's what idiots do and
that's what we've regressed with.
That's a regression.
We progress past that,
you know,
the uncultured and the society is
unlike.
That's what animals do.
Animals and babies fight and I'm like,
fuck you,
you know,
I'm sorry that you're a lopsided
individual and that you actually,
the physicality,
the physical part of your brain and your
body are basically defunct and you've
thrown that away and you think that
somehow that makes you a superior human
being because actually what it makes
you,
it makes you a defect.
You're the kind of thing that I don't
want to be out there breeding to make a
better human race because you're not
gunna.
Because you've decided to throw away a
part of it is as essential as a human
being and fighting doesn't have to be
angry,
violent,
animalistic,
just to dogs and cats going at it,
you know,
that kind of thing.
It has,
it can be so much more than that and it
doesn't in any physical endeavor is more
than that and can be more than that.
And it was just such a Shitty,
narrow point of view that I thought,
well,
for someone who supposed to be so
educated to say such a thing,
like it really got under my fucking
skin,
like mad,
like maybe
up on it.
But I just thought it was ridiculous to
say that,
look,
I've been in the presence of people who
have called me an idiot for doing
martial arts or even working out,
you know,
I've had like,
the people mock that you take care of
your body and it's just a defense
mechanism because they're smoking
cigarettes.
I didn't know they're rotting themselves
away.
And so there's some weird justification
that there's like an intellectual
argument for the finite lifespan of the
human being and why.
Fuck with it anyway.
Why even worry about it?
What do you.
What do you do when you're trying to
stay alive forever?
What are you doing?
Eating Greens and taking your vitamins.
What have you taken?
Steroids?
What are you trying to live forever and
you know that that attitude of they
can't be bothered with exercise like,
well,
that is one of the dumbest things you're
telling me.
You're an intelligent person.
You want me to respect your opinion.
You have these cynical points of views
on things,
but yet you're not taking care of your
meat vehicle.
Right?
Okay.
What are you retarded?
The thing that holds the brain,
the computer.
Then all this I suppose,
and intelligence and wisdom and and all
of the filter that you have to do
everything in the spew out.
Anything that you experienced in the
world exists within this.
You don't just drive a car into the
fucking ground and throw it away.
It's dumb.
Yeah.
If you,
if your car works,
take care of it.
Okay.
Change the oil stupid.
And when you deal with people that
somehow or another words,
it's hilarious.
That is.
There's like a whole section of humanity
that thinks that for some reason that
they,
by issuing anything physical and
sweating and that they are a superior
intellect,
the judge,
a person like yourself or anybody who's
doing something physical as being an
inferior intellect,
you almost automatically get
categorized.
Oh,
you are a,
a,
a martial artist.
Oh you,
you fucked up.
Cute on you.
Must be dumb.
Oh,
that's great.
I can't wait.
I'm glad that you can push a broom
better than somebody else.
Now it's like no asshole.
It's not.
Got nothing to do with that.
And while,
yes,
I could out broom you,
but uh,
and probably out fuck your wife,
but probably either way be able to wrap
their head around what it must've been
like to be in.
Like what was the biggest arena you guys
played in Japan?
Tokyo national outdoor stadium.
Ninety $3,000.
Went out there with Bob Sapp and called
out Nogueira right in front of 93,000
fans in Japanese.
3,000
people.
Holy Shit.
Who did you fight?
I didn't get to fight thing.
I wish I could have.
I was Bob's coach.
I walked out and then I got into the
center of the ring called out Nogueira
after beating bombed.
What's the biggest crowd that you ever
had?
Was it 50,000
at the Tokyo Dome when I fought a shaky
Takahashi defending the king of pancreas
belt for new Japan pro wrestling.
Ultimate crushed too.
I was 55,
I think it was 60,000
Andrea Rogers Centre in Toronto for the
George St Pierre and Jake Shields and
that was insane.
It's nuts and I was,
I mean also to add to.
I fought in front of like 50,
55,000
people.
I fought on the same car where a Leo toe
made his uh,
his debut.
So I knew that kid when we all,
the only way we could converse was
through Japanese because he didn't
really speak English at the time and I
didn't speak any Portuguese.
And then that card why fought,
you know,
50 in front of 50,000
plus I've fought on the same car.
That whole cogan wrestled on
mix it up with pro wrestling as well.
Right.
That was a big thing in Japan,
right?
Like they,
they would,
they would mix in pro wrestling and then
they would also have pro wrestlers who
would fight shoots,
they would fight real mma fight.
There was a real,
um,
want to try and bridge that gap again
and you know,
what it takes the right individual and
it takes the right kind of planning.
There wasn't really a good amount of
planning put behind getting those
wrestlers prepared to do it.
They were just really,
a lot of them were just shoved into
these scenarios where Yakuza no,
just by,
they're just my Japanese,
a bureaucracy.
Politics as it is,
like,
you know,
this is your shot is,
is your boss or whatever.
Like if he says,
go do this and you really gotTa fucking
do it.
And that's just the way it goes.
If you're a big time pro wrestler to
Takata and your,
your boss comes out.
Takotna was a huge progress for big,
handsome Japanese motherfucker,
right?
Um,
he went into MMA and he had a couple of
fishy fights,
like the forum with Coleman that was
fishy as Coleman is a goddamn terrible
actor.
I love Mark Coleman.
I love the hammer.
He's the original.
Matt Hamill.
Was that he just had a birthday.
Yeah,
I love the fuck out of that dude.
He's important due to hang out with
Lundbeck.
I tell him he's got amazing stories for
days.
He's great to work with.
He's a good dude too.
I hung out with him when he was the
champ in Augusta,
Georgia.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
We went to this crazy club that was
like,
it was,
it wasn't like a house,
like someone had turned the house into a
club.
I mean,
it was a mess about,
uh,
you know,
it was like in the nineties when he was
the champ.
Awesome.
The godfather of ground and pound love
Coleman.
But his fight with Dakota was clearly
fucker.
And so.
Okay.
So here's an example.
Well,
so,
uh,
I find a Gnocchi bond by 2003,
I think
it was.
I don't understand what we're talking
about.
We're talking about fixed fights.
We're talking about.
There was a few fights where they had
predetermined outcomes because they
wanted these big Japanese Superhero
dudes to,
to win.
And there was a couple of them that were
kind of obvious.
So,
uh,
I'm fine finding this,
an Okie Bombay card and Kobe stadium
that was a combination card because this
card was all filed,
eliminate.
This one was all fights and uh,
I fought some shield night,
defended the king of pancrase title
against who is the former king of
pancreas guy before me.
So,
uh,
so it was a rematch against semi and uh,
on that same card as my friend,
a fellow new Japan pro wrestling at the
time.
And it still is Eugene anegada fought,
fueled our.
And here's the thing,
he got pushed into that like three or
four weeks out.
Oh,
my niece.
And his attitude was just like,
all right,
well this,
you know,
I got to do it.
They want them,
they want me to fight him.
So to make sure that this guy in the
fuel basically fights on this card and
they have a match where people are going
to be all interested to see it because
I'm another name,
I'll do it.
And so I did my best to help him out,
train him.
I even paid stitch to who was there with
me as my cut and quarter guy to go to
wrap his hands and work on his cuts too,
and I did the best I could and I
cornered the Kata and you know,
there wasn't all right corner to Nevada
and they're just eating.
He just wasn't.
He Won.
He's not even fighting.
I mean we used to spar and wrestle and
grapple and do all kinds of stuff on
tour all the time.
Here we are always working out together,
but that's way different from training
for a fight and they're trying to fight
one of the absolute best guys in the
world.
And then on like three weeks,
notice it.
The a trouper man.
He's a real fucking awesome dude.
But he got pushed into it.
There's a different attitude though.
They're in Japan to organize what it's
called.
She organized means it can't be helped.
So that's basically the attitude is if
you know something shit,
he goes down,
whatever reactor start melting down and
you as this technician or just going to
go in there knowing you're going to
basically your community,
you're going to die and you're going to
go into your ship.
That thing down anyways,
Shogun,
I can't be helped.
That's hard for us to understand.
Well that's why a tragedy hits Japan
like that and people stand in line,
don't flip out.
They take care of each other,
but it's beautiful.
Really.
It is.
And that's a.
That was another thing like the cultures
around the world are all different in
the way they operate are all different.
So like when all the crazy shit that's
been going on in the U,
s and then people are going rampant like
rabid dogs throwing out statistics from
this country and that country and this
country all about different things and
it's like you can't really compare us to
Japan or us to the UK or us.
Like every.
They're all different cultures and you
may only can compare America to America
and the way that we are.
People are educated.
The way that our government system
works,
the way that the populace is divided up
in the land that they live in,
the type of philosophies that they carry
and the culture that drives them makes
them unique to America and no place
else.
Yeah.
It's hard to wrap your head around that.
For a lot of people.
They think that,
you know,
if we have
the same access to weapons as people do
in other parts of the world and we'd
have the same results,
but that's not the case because you look
at parts of Africa where we've got
complete total immersion and crime,
you know,
like you look at Liberia and the amount
of guns and violence and stuff.
Like there's parts of the world that are
just violent
that just murdering each other everyday.
Just about this apparently South Africa.
Even the,
the,
what you think of as a civilized more
um,
uh,
developed parts of Africa in terms of
like a society and a or like just like
city and modern type infrastructure.
I'm not here to,
to,
to declare that,
you know,
one way of living is better than say,
an aboriginal,
right.
Whatever,
who cares?
You were just talking about technology,
right?
So even in those,
I mean there's like these people,
you know,
that BMW has an,
an option.
And I got this from a,
from a South African who was telling me
about this.
I was down racing the Baja 1001 of these
guys,
uh,
working with the company,
a wide open was telling me about,
uh,
about living in South Africa and how BMW
has a factory option at the dealerships.
And,
or I think it's a factory often,
or at least it's only offered in South
Africa.
Your bmw,
you can order an antique car jacking a
package and you want to hear what this
antique car jacking packages.
Yes.
Okay.
What they do is they install propane
tanks into these cars and they put a set
of burners along the the side trim down
there and below the door,
so if somebody comes and take car jack
you because it is so prevalent,
you hit this [inaudible] button and
flames shoot out the fucking car and you
char them to death.
I love that.
And you know what the cops do,
they come rolling up in South Africa.
They're like,
oh,
another one.
Wow,
I need to get that.
And have you seen that?
Can pull that up.
Little feverish.
I don't even know how true this is,
but I've seen the thing rolling around
on facebook and whatever about some
female doctor in South Africa because
rape is so such a fricking often rape
content.
They make that insertion device with
barbs in it.
Yes,
it does.
Can you imagine living in a society
where you have to wear as a woman,
you have to wear a condom with spikes in
it,
but to protect yourself from rape?
Yeah,
because there's.
There's that much rape going on.
It's basically like the jungle.
How W W as close.
Closest people can get to in terms of
behavior.
Uh,
another thing,
my buddy from South Africa was telling
me about his,
uh,
at one point.
So he,
he did get,
so they have tricky ways of carjacking,
you know,
down there.
So he does,
he gets car jacked and he's not in his
car and uh,
in a way that he can hit this burners
and kill these fuckers.
So they carjack um,
they,
they run off and whatever and the cops
show up and the cops chase them down and
shoot these fuckers.
But in the midst of that,
where they leave the guy,
they have to leave the guy to go track
down these dudes.
So my friends just sitting there and
they go,
hey,
here you go.
And they just hand them a specter
submachine gun a go.
All right,
if these guys come back around to shoot
him.
Whoa.
So there is,
here's the place.
But Cole have guns.
The cops just gave him a gun and told
him to wipe this dude.
Here's a machine gun.
Hold your ground.
Holy Fuck.
Here's the car jacking.
They,
I've actually seen this before.
It's crazy.
Oh my goodness.
I need to see this.
God bless you.
Bye.
Holy Fuck.
Why don't they just Jackie from the back
door.
They have ways of trying to do.
They're going to do this on somebody.
Somebody get cooked.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
That is the coolest fucking thing I've
ever seen in my life.
And that's what people are living in.
What if you missed that switch?
What if you're texting while you're
driving?
You hit that switch.
Look at this.
Okay.
Hey,
I'm sorry.
Let me hit this switch real quick.
Where you got this gun in my face.
Oh No,
it's not a flame thrower that I'm
fighting for pain.
You smell that says,
wow,
you need bulletproof class too.
They probably offer that.
Can you imagine getting in a car
accident?
Your car just blow up.
God bless you.
God you to see BMW.
So,
so that's what I'm talking about.
And that,
you know,
it's,
yeah,
there's cultures and societies are
radically different everywhere now.
We don't necessarily need flame thrower,
you know,
things on our cars.
I mean,
there are probably,
are parts of the US,
Detroit potentially,
I don't know,
a whole lot about Detroit supposed to be
the best,
you know,
it's supposed to be real bad,
but uh,
I mean that is a viable option.
I mean,
that could be unnecessary and it's not
because I want to run around flame
throwing people for freedom,
although I try to do most things for
freedom as long as you do it with a good
country music background.
And the belt buckles big something six.
He gets something hanging in the
background.
Yeah,
you burn you Lug Eagle inside my heart,
fire straight from Jesus,
the blood guy.
So,
uh,
I mean,
but how about this,
you know,
think about,
Oh,
you're driving in your car,
you've got your kids and whatever.
And some asshole comes up.
He wants to carjack you and let's just
be honest.
One send me,
somebody starts pulling guns,
knives,
any type of weapon he wants to do harm
to you,
but for,
for his own purposes,
you have no idea what they're going to
do.
Oh,
well he's just going to know he's not.
You don't know if he's just going to
steal your shit.
No,
you have no clue.
I mean,
there was a report of a these dudes and
like,
um,
I don't know if it was Mississippi.
It was,
it was like a bad news ghetto area,
right?
It was like a gnarly spot where these
were folks who were living and
apparently these dudes carjack some
little couple and took them back,
took their car,
took their shit,
took them back to their,
to their,
to the residence or wherever we're were
were these,
uh,
these nefarious dudes or staying and
then tortured and raped them and killed
them.
And then through their bodies in a trap
and a dumpster.
Okay.
So it wasn't even enough to just take
someone's car,
their possessions and belongings,
but took like this boyfriend,
girlfriend and fucking mutilated them
and did horrible shit to him and then
kill them.
And uh,
you're like,
well it can.
That's just the thing is that you don't
know what somebody who has ill intent
for you is,
it really has up to do.
So I've had people talk to me about
like,
oh,
what happens if he pulls a gun on you?
I'm like,
like give them what they want,
you know what I mean?
I'm not trying to to bargain my life
versus a bullet over a wallet with some
money in it or whatever.
Like that's just not that important.
But I also think in my head like you
have to assess a situation and it might
become absolutely clear that I'm,
this guy might not have any intention of
letting me go.
There's a lot of that in the world or
you know,
if someone pulls a knife on me,
I'm like,
I got,
I hope never.
And I like why I go because if someone
pulls a knife on me,
I'm going to murder them.
If I have to.
Like I'm not going to stop until he's
dead because he's got a fucking knife.
I don't know where his friends are.
I don't know anything about what's going
on.
All I know is it the minutes a weapon
gets pulled on my person.
They intend for me to die.
Whether they actually don't have the
guts to go through with it or not,
or maybe that just they just want my
belongings.
I don't know that shit.
I can't read minds.
I just know someone wants to cut and
like kill me to my shit.
I think there's a real,
there's a mindset that a lot of people
have where if you concentrate on things
like that,
you could sort of manifest it and if you
spend all your time worrying about
people attacking you,
then you know you're going to invite
that shit into your life.
There's a lot of people that really
believe that and they also believe that,
you know,
really the,
the evolved way to be is to just never,
never get into any sort of an
altercation with anybody and try to keep
society as civil as possible and as many
last as possible.
Yeah,
I see their point of view.
But uh,
the real problem is the randomness of
life.
Oh,
I see their point of view too,
but I think it's pretty obvious where
that type of concept goes.
I mean,
it's like killed.
Well,
you can get,
not only can you get killed,
but now all of a sudden you take away
the ability to be the kind of any kind
of per person than any individual that
you want to be.
All of a sudden you become some you can.
Part of this.
I'm fucked up and ran novel.
We can't even use the word I anymore.
You know?
It's like,
whoa.
That's why would you want to.
That's yeah,
it may be peaceful,
but how is that?
That's a repression of of the human
spirit and and like that.
There's no growth in that.
Well,
not only that,
you're allowing,
you're doing a shitty job of preserving
your own excellent genetics by allowing
some cut bag to take you out.
Of course,
when you intellectually,
you have made a decision early in your
life to prepare for something like this
so that if something goes down,
you're not physically completely inapt
and you get to decide whether or not you
get injured or not,
and if somebody goes to do you bodily
harm and they don't understand that
you're a trained killer,
boom,
you survive and they don't.
Whereas another person in the same
situation,
you could think you're smart all day,
but now you're dead.
Okay.
Smart enough to fucking stop from
getting your ass pummeled to death on
the street.
And the thing is,
it could be as simple as a home dude
from a nxs right?
He a guy jerking off.
No,
no,
no
guy.
That guy died jerking off.
No,
he got it from Nsx in excess.
He killed himself.
You know,
he,
he died.
It was auto erotic association is one of
a slew.
Trust me,
I'm a God damn.
Okay.
Well that may be so,
but up leading up to that point,
uh,
he was drunk as fuck apparently.
And got an altercation with somebody
you've got shoved and he fell and he has
head on a curb and the repercussions
from that was a,
he received brain damage to where he
couldn't smell or taste anymore really?
And it drove him nuts.
Oh my God.
Himself.
But that was just simply falling down,
hitting his head and he could hit his
head on the curb like 50 times.
And who knows how it could turn out,
you know,
it could have burned him right there and
killed him or taken done.
Just given them a crack and needed some
stitches.
It could be just a big goose egg.
How long did it last forum?
Like A.
I think it was a permanent thing for how
many years?
I don't know.
I don't know,
but I believe it was a permanent thing,
like it wasn't coming back so he
couldn't taste anything.
Taste or smell Jesus Christ.
How would you know?
Like what policies?
Miles.
That was actually what was described to
me as part of the huge issue was that he
loved
how much you can never taste a woman
ever again.
Yeah.
I mean that's a horrible fucking thing
to think of,
but that's also to show you that you
know,
the randomness you could fall off,
you could fall from,
you know,
10,000
feet in the air and you're shooting wide
open balance.
Break every bone in your body and live
through it.
I mean fuck.
The human body is pretty amazing what it
can go through.
I mean,
I should be some sort of a,
um,
a example of that as a fighter of 15
years and all the fucking Shit I've been
through and yet I'm a walking,
talking,
moving capable human being still and
being physically fit does help with that
and all my flight training and the few
accidents I've ever been in where people
have hit me in,
my car's a,
all that training,
all that sparring,
all that time spent in the gym and being
in those,
you know,
those,
uh,
fight or flight scenario isn't that high
intensity shit.
The whole world slows down to me and I'm
completely cognizant,
aware and capable where I know if you
were a person that did not train and
hone your focus and your physicality and
your mental fortitude,
you just fucking,
you.
But I don't know what happened either
and they just flip out and they wouldn't
be able to be cognizant or aware in that
moment at all.
It says that he was found dead.
He committed suicide apparently.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm wrong.
I thought he was an autoerotic
appreciation guy and he's really big on
your,
uh,
on your choking and jerking off and I
don't know why.
That's my thing.
Um,
there was a.
I know,
I apologize to the family of Mr
Hutchings.
I thought he said it had been suggested,
but there was no evidence that found it.
Maybe it was one of those like Richard
Gere Journal warrant rumor thing.
Just some spreading through.
Have you ever double up your ass?
No.
No,
no,
no.
Jesus shutting yourself off when you
jerk off with a job up here.
No,
I don't need to.
I don't need to truck myself off while I
beat off.
I'm fine with regular feeding.
Regular bed.
It's always worked well for me.
It's quite,
quite satisfied.
Yeah.
I,
I'm pretty happy with it myself.
I'm a big fan.
I don't,
I really don't find any need to improve
it.
It's like when girls started putting
like tongue rings in.
Oh,
it helps when you give him blow jobs,
guess what?
It doesn't really help.
It's just a new thing.
The only thing that make it maybe in
your mind,
it's like,
oh,
she's sucking my cock with like this
weird piece of jewelry.
Like I had a couple girls that have had
pierce pussies and like
on any better.
No.
The weird thing about the peers tongue
is they're letting you know that down
the sucks cock.
That's like in a way.
Yeah.
That's a green light.
Any girl who lives in 10 years time and
doesn't suck,
there's a target to shoot some loads
down to fuck.
Awesome.
Are the cereal bowl.
Girls don't have stamps if they're not
down to fuck.
I mean if a girl does not like sex just
to put a goddamn target on her lower
back.
Right?
And if a girl doesn't like giving head,
she doesn't walk around with a barbell
in her mouth.
Uh,
yeah.
That's what you're thinking about
shooting loads on that thing.
You know what you're doing.
You dirty bitch.
You know what you're trying to do.
God Damn it.
Don't pretend any girl who has a tongue
ring.
Give head is an asshole.
If you're a girl,
you have a ton.
Or if you're a guy,
if you're a guy,
you don't give her head with the time
you
think about that.
If you're a guy with a tongue ring,
you don't eat pussy,
you can go fuck yourself.
How about that silly bitch pussy
anyways,
you're a pretty horrible person.
Signs,
there's a reason why it smells bad.
Okay?
That's nature.
Telling you to get the fuck out of
there.
You're not the only one is using this,
this watering hole.
It's a battle of loads going on inside
that snatch right now.
There is no way to cleanse this thing,
right?
This is a bad news deal.
You need to get out of there.
Isn't it funny that that smell?
It's the smell of shit and the smell of
dirty pussy,
man,
that's debatable.
I'll tell you a yeast infection smell is
just as bad or worse.
Shin shit sharp and and it's like this
sort of gets on your tongue is even if
you don't eat it,
you're just like,
oh I want to fleet.
Whereas Shit makes you want to clean it
up.
You know?
If you smell shit you like Jay,
you smelled dirty.
You don't want to clean it up,
you just want it to be gone.
I spray with Lysol and kick it out the
door.
You never gone down on a girl and you
smell her dirty ass hole.
Some girls,
they don't use baby wipes.
They wipe their ass with paper towels
and shift.
It's a terrible,
terrible thing where you're trying to
concentrate on eating pussy and you
smell the asshole next door.
Just stinking up the box,
but you don't want to give up because
her pussy doesn't smell bad.
It's just a smell shit.
You just want to clean her up so you
know,
you just,
he's just take a little bit of the uh,
the sheets and just kind of roll it up
on top.
A little handover it a little palm.
Actually.
Blogging.
By the way,
this is the moment when we lost all of
our female listeners.
I'm sorry if you're hanging in there.
God bless you.
Want to turn the ship around?
We're going to bring it back to here
that we're talking about.
The ast may stink.
Alright?
You want to use the Brillo pad on it
instead of something proper.
And here,
look,
I'm still down there trying to do our
job.
I'm trying to get to the bottom of that
horrific smell.
Like the.
I know women get uncomfortable,
but the subject I've had girls I get
really mad at me for even broaching the
subject line.
It's like a rotten squid,
like rolled in a pile of six month old.
Catch it.
And then by the way,
I'm not talking about talking about the
woman who has the.
I would never do that.
I'm not rude.
I mean I'd probably let you know you got
a little issue,
but I wouldn't be like really graphic.
You've got to be cool about it.
Like fucking fun up.
Weird Shit.
The best thing you can do is like,
look,
if there's like some sort of a bv thing
going on or anything like that.
Be a fucking cool dude.
Please.
Okay.
You're fucking a girl in the ass and
there's a little poop.
All right,
I'll tell him,
don't flip out about it.
Go in the shower and then get back to it
and you know what?
And then,
you know,
probably this chick's gonna be like,
Oh my God.
I'm like,
I don't give her a hug and be like,
fuck that.
Who Cares?
The other girl look it up.
Yeah,
exactly.
Other girl.
Brian,
you rolling like you bring it across the
room.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're an artist you can make a
painting out of it.
But even if you were talking about the
subject of Stinky vaginas with a girl
who's vagina doesn't sink,
nobody likes desktop.
They'll be like,
stop.
Stop.
It's like you're bringing up candyman
and you're saying his name twice.
Somehow.
Tony Todd's going to come flying out of
her vagina.
Look,
what's that weird thing?
It's everywhere.
It's nature.
Literally telling you to get away.
Like the smell of like a yeast infection
is like,
it's repulsive.
It's making you fully like.
It literally makes you fat,
doesn't then the Kurds coming out.
Are you using that?
How dare you?
I dare.
Yeah.
What is that?
Think of that with peaches on it.
How come sometimes that cheesy stuff
doesn't smell bad at all.
You don't even care like some.
Sometimes girls just get overly Horny
and they start producing yogurt.
Yeah.
I think it's the beginning of or the end
of one.
Is that what it is?
Well,
there's also that cream.
Some girls have that creamy white stuff
that they.
They start,
you know,
some more than other than it's a,
it's a fucking potent man.
It's,
it's a serious.
It's like eating flog raw kind of a
girl.
I dated when I was a young girl,
a day when I was a teenager would get so
wet it would run down her leg.
Oh yes.
Like literally.
Oh yeah.
I mean all the way down a few of them
below her knee starts bubbling and you
know,
yeah.
It didn't even make any sense.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
She would just.
And it was all pussy lube,
like everything will be all slippery.
She was just fucking going and you know,
there is a thing about,
there's a problem with a,
not a problem,
but just one thing you have to take into
account or you get the.
I've had a few girls that just crazy
wetness.
I like to think it's all attributed to
me,
but I'm such A.
I'm such a fucking manly stud,
stead,
Meister,
you know,
I,
I've put my hands on them the way I
like,
kicked the cat out of the way.
We're working on the bed.
That's important sometimes for girls
fucking throw the animals out of the
room,
but it can get to the point where it's
so wet.
You gotta you just gotTa wipe away,
man.
You gotta you gotta clean off and keep
going because you can't feel anything.
It's just like girls that just goes
overboard.
But fortunately I have a gigantic cox so
that's not an issue.
Oh perfect.
So it's tight.
It just fucking just stretches that
whole St.
they should drink pedialyte so they
don't,
you know,
dehydrated.
So I was thinking to myself because I
thought when I don't have a gigantic car
in the interest of full disclosure,
I don't want a lot of the people,
but when we're going to come up to you
at a show and be like,
Joe,
let me see how big your cock is.
Like it was just when I was dating this
girl.
Obviously I didn't know any better.
I was only like 18,
19 years old.
I didn't know that everybody wasn't like
that.
I didn't know that one day.
You know,
like a lot of like young girls,
they get really wet,
but then you get older and you realize,
oh wait a minute.
That was like his wet as a girl ever got
ever.
And they're like,
oh,
well that was our prime.
Like her baby making prime was when she
was 16,
17.
Maybe she just had less hangups with
women.
Then it's all about the brain.
Like if they don't want to come,
they ain't coming.
Some girls can't come right now.
There's that,
which is a tragedy because they,
they should uh,
you know,
have that out.
I mean,
it's up to them and you've got girls
will say to you,
no,
fuck you,
you didn't,
you didn't make her calm.
She can come.
You just can't make her kind of like,
trust me.
There's some,
there's some girls that were technical
difficulty or something,
you know,
you don't put it out right.
But honestly,
like a lot of times it's really.
And you know,
if she's not
comfortable at 100 percent,
she's not where she needs to be,
or even if she's not comfortable with
her body enough to know how to make
herself call sensitive,
you know,
I get in there.
How you doing?
Do you want me to release these
medicals?
Are they too tight?
You want me to let you out of the
basement,
Joshua?
It's like the Grad data in high school.
I could fit so easily.
Every thought,
every girl you could fit.
Every girl was festival when your hands
were little back then you were just
growing up.
If I can,
if I can at least karate chop.
I'm a little bit and I'm good to go.
Well,
it's,
it's funny how one girl respond to one
thing.
Then you try that on another girl in the
fucking angry.
Well,
you know what I get.
Okay.
How about some uniformity?
Here's something now I'm.
Maybe this would make sense or not,
but.
So I,
I,
I was in a relationship for almost eight
years now.
I'm super loyal,
dude.
Don't fuck around.
Don't play around.
That's my thing.
When I'm in one,
I'm in one,
when I'm not,
I'm not.
And uh,
I became newly single and so,
uh,
you know,
first off I get to do at the time,
at the time,
do,
do that newly single.
And so,
uh,
first thing I'm going on,
I'm trying to go out on the town every
and uh,
you know,
people are like,
oh,
especially the chicks that you'd run
into rob.
You just have groupies everywhere.
He just fucking everything all the time.
We just got all porn.
I go,
yeah,
actually,
in a way,
I've got tons of groupies straight men
who form a barrier around me buying me
all the fucking drinks I want by me all
the shots wanting to feel like pushing
girls out of the way.
I can't get a single piece of pussy
because they can't get through that wall
of caulk that surrounding me.
And so,
uh,
and,
and every girl was like mine every year,
lying yourself,
Holy Shit.
Like,
you're just such a playboy.
I'm like,
okay.
So,
uh,
so at any point,
I finally start finding a few gals that
are,
they're down to like,
they're cool.
They read books,
go for coffee,
right?
Yeah.
We're chilling or we're talking about
the new operating system on our,
our Max Roller Ball that the dog catcher
and bring it back.
Absolutely.
Um,
and so I find some chicks that are cool
and respectable.
They're not assholes or whatever and
we're were,
all right,
cool,
let's,
we'll fucking hang out.
And all of a sudden I get,
start getting all these girls and want
physicality.
Like,
Oh yeah,
held up,
whacked around,
smacked around,
fucking thrown all over the place,
Aka my ex girlfriend.
And I'm like,
I started to think for,
I'm talking to my buddies.
I'm like,
is it because I'm a big physical dude
now I'm a fighter.
Like I don't think they're this way
necessarily with everybody,
like,
and they want me to do shit.
Never done.
And of course I'm more than willing to
oblige.
Well,
you have to,
but do you do judge them?
Know,
you know?
Well,
I mean every,
every,
every person is different and you can
definitely tell the difference between
ones where there's like,
okay,
there's some psychological fucking
issues going on here and some that just,
they see me as the facilitator of a,
of an open fucking apparently Aka the
good ones I guess.
Yeah.
Those are the ones that are guilt.
No,
no.
I've had plenty of chicks that liked
getting the shit ragdoll out of them,
but we're awesome.
SMART,
normal mean.
Just good people like they're red and
their bedroom habits don't necessarily
aren't always an indication of what
somebody is as a person.
That's always like one of my big issues.
Why people are always being such
assholes about gay people.
It's like I don't give a fuck what he or
her does.
If they're gay at all,
like how has that?
That's not.
They are a amalgamation of all these
different things and who they fuck is
only one small part of it.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's an.
It's a dumb person's argument.
Either dumb or my joke is you the dumb
or you secretly worried that dicks are
delicious.
Those are the only two reasons why you'd
be upset.
Well,
my Dick seems to be very delicious as
far as how flexible are you,
John?
Well,
I can't rubber guard so I have to still
keep finding these chicks,
but I've been told by the time my
dictates famous,
I had been told that famous,
that you're dictates famous w,
w.
What else did he tell you?
My now where people are getting so super
angry because the sound levels are not
equalized.
Hey,
what can we do to do this?
There's something we can do about that,
Brian,
because people are constantly
complaining,
but they're always complaining that this
out of 1 million people that listen to
it,
there's always going to be two people
that tweet you but the sound,
but apparently there are large spikes.
If you have something you're always
going to have,
you're always going to have large
spikes.
It's if you have certain people like
joey ideas.
Where's that Josh Barnett fucking Viking
Shit going on here.
Well,
you know,
here's the thing,
like a and anybody that's completely
cool and love something,
they often don't say a fucking thing
right?
Anybody that wants to be a negative
piece of shit like go out there and
spoil it for everyone and just shit all
over the world with all their negative
garbage bullshit.
They want to talk the most people with
the least to say want to be heard them.
Okay.
So there's a little bit,
but there also is a lot of.
I learned a lot from the criticism that
I'm not applying that with a broad brush
across.
I know I'm just,
I'm just saying I need to qualify myself
because I don't want people to think a
lot.
A lot of the shit that people have said
to us about the show and me as a standup
and me as a commentator and it means a
comedian I said that are sort of twice.
Um,
I've learned a lot from douche bags.
Like it's,
it seems like you wouldn't because
they're there being county,
but then you got to say,
well,
if they even have a point,
like even a tiny point,
they can say something and then all you
have to do is figure out what that thing
is and take that away.
Like if you have a fix that weakness,
now they can't say shit.
Sure.
If they do say Shit,
well then it doesn't mean anything
anymore.
It only means something.
If you really feel like there's some
merit to what they're saying,
some of the dumbest,
just most asinine trite that gets thrown
at you.
It's not always easy to do,
but you realize,
I mean it is possible to learn in some
way from all of this shit.
Sometimes it isn't anything learning
necessarily directly about you,
but this could be by seeing what this
person is doing,
being on the receiving end of these
things and you can look back and you can
think about,
well,
how have I done anything remotely like
that in my own life?
How?
How have I ever acted in such a way that
is on that same level of like just
shittiness this guy is doing to me?
Or why is it that people or are are know
exerting this kind of terrible attitude.
You know,
via that anonymity.
I mean,
there's so many things that your brain
can go to where it's an opportunity for
you to to expand upon who you are as a
person.
There is something to take from it.
I'm not saying it's going to change your
life,
but I mean even some of the dumbest,
worst shit that's ever come my way and
sometimes I just get good material out
of it.
I just fucking started ripping on
people,
whatever,
and it's hilarious and it's still serve
me a purpose.
I still got something out of it
and it definitely does broaden your
understanding of the possibility of
human behavior and you learn a lot about
like why people act the way they act.
And here's the big one.
Haters like people who are really
douchey or all failures,
it's 100 percent across the board.
No one who is truly brilliant at
anything is a hater.
They're just not.
They might be a few jealous like sports.
They are a hater.
They're not going to go out publicly and
I hate her.
Well yeah,
and I mean to be truly excellent at
something,
you have to be concentrating on yourself
and positive shit and you can't be
worrying about shooting somebody down or
chipping too many down.
So like you are taking the opinions,
like if you're one of those guys that
gets in battles with haters a lot of
time online,
you know,
you could do it for fun if you want to,
but what you're doing essentially is
you're arguing with like some of the
biggest failures as a human being that
exists usually
person that's like,
I mean,
you know,
uh,
I'm gonna,
I'm just gonna drop out of high school
and get my ged and graduated early.
That person,
that's if you're lucky.
You know what I mean?
But even if they have a job somewhere,
it doesn't matter.
It's like you're,
you're socially unsuccessful.
Like there was that guy that was,
he lost his job.
What's his name?
Brian.
You know what I'm talking about?
The reddit guy,
he was responsible for like someone like
the most heinous,
fucked up shit on reddit.com.
Like yeah,
like underage girls like suggested
positions and like some dark shit and it
was like really rude online.
Well they found out his name,
they went out and they got them and they
contacted his employer and then they got
the guy fired and then he was on some
television show,
sort of defending it saying this is a
character that he plays online and that
it gives them freedom or it's
too far.
It's bullshit.
Like you know what,
I don't care if it's a character you
even when you're just reading a bunch of
texts,
like you can't tell who's a fucking
character or not and,
and there's no way to interpret that
when Andy Kaufman goes on stage and no
matter what crazy shit he was doing,
he wasn't out there trying to,
to really fuck up people's lives.
Like you maybe you show up at a show and
he sings,
you know,
a cartoon theme songs or actually he
just lip syncs.
So the whole time,
okay,
you're mad.
You may as you spent your money to go
see it,
but he didn't ruin your fucking
life.
He didn't cause you some sort of a
difficulty.
He didn't do something and it's like,
Fuck Dude,
what?
That,
you know,
he didn't impact you in such a negative
way that made you want to kill them.
And there's there,
there used to be a,
uh,
an mma for them.
The same thing that fight sport.
Oh yeah.
I remember that.
They would just,
everything was just nothing but
negativity,
just horrible as shit.
There'd be people at portraying or maybe
for real,
like a racist personalities.
There'd be people digging up stuff on
other and just all of it was just to be
nothing but to be horrible to each other
and the other fighters and people.
And I'm like,
fuck,
you know,
why?
Why live your life that way?
Why spend all that energy?
And truly at the end of the day you
haven't gotten anywhere like you,
you've just been swimming in place.
You haven't improved your life.
You haven't gotten any further along and
trying to accomplish something for
yourself at all.
Well,
most of them are 12,
you know,
sad,
part of some of those are 30 to 20.
Maybe even 50 and this guy who got
caught,
the reddit guy who was a guy who had
children.
See why,
why would you,
why spend?
Because there's,
there's clearly,
clearly there's something lacking in his
life,
uh,
socially somehow that he never came to
grips with and he's using this anonymity
to do this and it's just that they have
a voice that didn't exist in the past
and in the past they were the person
that,
you know,
when they would be dealt with socially,
like in a one on one situation,
if they ever said anything,
anything remotely route,
everybody will be like,
fuck you stupid.
Look at you.
You'd dump fat.
Fuck.
And they'd be shot down.
It will be over,
but they can lash out at you without any
fields of social repercussions.
Just brought something really that
really just went off in my head.
All right,
Joe Comedian.
Yes sir.
Comedians throw out heinous shit
sometimes you know,
but jokes are jokes are jokes and you
fucking,
you,
you throw as you give out as much as you
got.
But that's the only way that you can
throw out as much as you got,
you know,
in terms of being a comedian and pushing
boundaries and saying crazy shit
sometimes whatever is because you will
need to take as much as you get.
And that's the difference there.
Like,
don't go out there and say some rude
shit even if you're trying,
even if you're doing the right thing to
go out and stand up and say something
that is against somebody else or some
other groups are because even if it's
the wrong thing that they're doing and
you need to stand up as some sort of a,
uh,
um,
avatar against it because it's the wrong
fucking thing.
It's not good to do.
That means you have to be willing to
accept every negative thing that's going
to come with that and be okay with that.
And be like,
you know,
to do,
to go out there and stand up for the
right thing.
Something shitty might come my way.
But this is something that must be done.
And even if in a social scenario of
your,
oh,
I'm going to where everyone's a pot
shouting each other,
you know,
and,
and it's,
it's fun,
but to say something,
you know,
to insult somebody else,
even in a fun and adjust way,
you can't do it if you can't fucking
take it because we've all known those
people were all fucking around,
were saying horrible shit to each other
and somebody chimes in and,
and,
and that's what's funny is there's
always a change in tone when that guy
does it from everybody's response to
them because you can,
it's like you can feel the shit that
they're saying and not being able to
take it.
And the place they're coming from,
it's like,
it,
it could come out their mouth the same,
but there's a different energy and if
you turn to them and then you're like,
fuck you,
you piece of shit,
shut the fuck up.
And it changes.
It's like,
it's different between you and me
riffing on it.
Sure.
He's serious.
And it was just joking around with
everybody else as long as he was
involved in the joking.
But we realized,
but it's like you,
you can read,
you can you realize that when they throw
out that thing,
they can't take it either and so they
shouldn't really be participating
because there just isn't,
isn't in the same vein.
Well,
that's what the thing about being able
to hate on someone,
especially a public person,
like a Josh Barnett type character,
which is your apparently wonderful to do
your anonymous because if you're just
some anonymous person,
you have no repercussions whatsoever.
You know so much about you.
They know what your look like.
They know the fights you've had.
Like I was watching some battle on
twitter or whatever the fuck it was.
I was reading on an mma site was Josh
Thompson was arguing with this guy and
the guy who was bringing up like me and
my friends,
we laughed out loud watching you get
Kayo by Eve's Edwards,
please fight again so we can laugh again
and you get knocked out.
And I'm,
and I'm why I'm like this.
This piece of shit like that is the
weakest and move of as a human being to
go after what you know her to guy.
Well,
you know,
it was a devastating loss.
The goal to go after that when you're
just,
when you haven't done anything yourself,
someone that put it out there.
Yeah,
they expose themselves to all the glory
and all the.
All the sadness and difficulty of
defeat.
He went and dared to do it and you don't
dare to do anything besides sit behind
an anonymous thing and and and really
accomplished nothing and try to take
shots at somebody who went out there and
tried who were not there.
Try went to excel and put himself in a
position where it's precarious and it's
difficult and there's no guarantees and
he knew that and he knew that everyone
would watch it and he and you also know
as a fire,
you go out there and you lose.
You're opening yourself up to all of
that for people to come out there and
use that as a weapon against you because
of their shitty a personality.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so to,
to do that,
it's fucking,
we of course don't argue with them
because they,
no one's paying attention to what the
fuck they have to say anyway.
So when you respond,
you give them exactly what they're
looking for.
Now.
Important.
Yeah.
And you know,
I,
I also think that this is not gonna
last.
I think this is an error in humanity
that we're going to figure out.
And I think it's already been too long.
Yeah,
kind of.
I don't.
I don't know when it's gonna end,
if it does end
well it sort of already has with this
reddit guy.
I mean it's,
it's,
they can track you down,
they can find out who the fuck you are.
If somebody is decently motivated,
you know,
for guys like you or I or Brian,
you,
you're,
you get a certain amount of access to
us.
You know,
you're on twitter,
you're on facebook,
you know,
people can write threads on the
underground,
you're going to read them,
you know,
there's,
there's a certain amount of access and
the Brian
though they should be.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Definitely.
No,
no.
Come on,
there's a certain amount of,
I mean you're,
you're,
you're gonna,
you're used to it and you can deal with
it,
but when it comes on them,
when all of a sudden their real name is
exposed and their employer is like,
all the sudden it's like whoa.
Then they realize like,
look,
you're,
you're in an ever changing game.
Okay,
and this anonymity that might've enjoyed
two years ago really doesn't exist
anymore and guess what?
In a year from now and be able to read
your thoughts.
Okay,
so keep it together,
keep it together and taking all this
stuff from onnit Dotcom that may even
come sooner
to be a better person.
You fuckhead and that's what people
don't understand.
They aren't trying to be better people
and that is what's killing this country
as it is people,
the human race period,
the human race period and it.
But it varies from place and I think
here in America we have a very specific
case.
Like I'm saying that it,
it's,
it is specific to us as Americans have
the way we use our technology,
the way that we are progressing or
regressing as individuals.
And uh,
there's,
there's this huge concept of uh,
so,
so one thing about people talking shit
about folks is that,
you know,
of course that is the anonymity,
but there's also this prevalent attitude
that I can go out there and be as much
of an asshole as I want because you're
not going to do anything about it.
You can't beat me up.
You can't just fight me like nobody.
Like nobody actually thinks that
anything will happen.
But oh well I'll sue you.
You should be able to you.
If someone talks shit to you and your a
problem and may fire,
you should at least be able to bitch
slap them a little bit.
Totally legal.
And,
and my thing is like,
even if,
uh,
if you're being outwardly with so many
people lack common courtesy anymore,
just the smallest things.
And if you do something that is
discourteous in a public manner and you
upset somebody,
well most people just fucking take it.
But if someone goes,
hey,
fuck you for doing x,
Y,
Z,
that's not cool.
Instead of someone being like,
all right,
either a,
I'm sorry,
you're right.
That was fucked up.
I shouldn't have done that.
And you know,
waking up a or b being like,
you know what,
fuck you,
I'm just an asshole.
So let's fight and dealing with it.
And then let's say they get their ass
beat and then they go about their way.
No,
no,
no.
It's always like,
they just keep pushing that barrier
because that boundary.
But,
and crossing that line because they
think you can do anything about it.
You can't just,
you know,
use freedom of speech.
I can be as much of a dickhead as I
want,
as long as they don't do anything to
you.
And it's okay.
Fine.
And I've,
I've had,
usually it is these things where I've
had,
where it's happened to me,
I've turned to him and I,
you know,
I tell them like in a movie theater,
fucking cell phone and the on the,
on the cell phone talking on it in the
middle of the movie theater,
I had to turn around.
I go,
are you fucking on your phone in the
middle of a movie?
Fucking kidding me.
And I looked at him and go get off that
fucking phone right now I'm a breaker
and a half and shove it up your ass.
And I say that because I slept.
Someone would say in a movie,
well there's that.
But also it's very appropriate.
It's very clinical.
When I,
I tried,
I pride myself on being.
If I say some shit like that after I've
said it during no turning back.
And if I say I'm going to do it,
I'm going to fucking do it because
otherwise my word is meaningless.
But you really shove it up their ass.
You might shove it up there.
I would break them a little,
like a bad baby.
Throw them across the chair,
maybe.
I Dunno,
but yeah,
I just went limp though.
You probably just scream and pick them
up and shake them them.
Yeah,
if they just went lamp,
they just completely fetal position.
I'd take that phone,
break it,
slam it on the phone,
tell him what a piece of shit they were
and they let it go.
But that's your move folks.
Listen,
you got to go limp.
Just go limp.
And if you can start crying,
just crying.
I go limp all the time.
It's that after I'm done.
Oh happens buddy.
I think this is a very important subject
and I love that you brought it up and I
think um,
this is a,
um,
a,
a really important subject for the young
men,
especially of this era that are growing
up now.
Just being forced fed video games and
not having any character
to build it.
They just leave the kid with the eye,
the portable portable gaming system.
And you know what?
I Love Games.
I gained a lot when I was a kid and I
loved it.
But guess what?
When I'm out with my parents or I'm at
family functions,
when I'm not sitting in a corner
completely buried into some electronics
the whole time being like,
fuck that.
Like you can't let your kid do that
shit.
Yeah,
definitely doesn't teach them.
That doesn't raise a good human skills,
but the mind what what concerns me is
the lack of character building things.
If you're not involved in some kind of
athletics,
then to me if you're.
It's either that or some other difficult
intellectual pursuit,
but there's something that has to
happen.
They need to suffer being being,
being made to,
to have some,
you know,
a push.
Yeah.
To be able to realize that you will fail
and learn from the failures.
Objective.
Lee,
one of the most important things you
could ever learn as a man is how you
fucked up and how not to fuck up again
because you understand the pain of
fucking up.
One of the saddest thing to it too,
and one of the saddest things is when
you see rich kids,
kids that grow up with no character and
no one ever tells them what to do with
fucking up.
Yeah,
they got to cook all their life.
That takes.
Here's the other one.
They don't understand that the reason
that they're able to create a business
doing this or do that or have all this
little successful shit running around
them is because they had all the
facilities to do it in the first place.
They didn't have to strive and struggle
and fucking,
you know,
oh,
you fuck up.
I've got money to cover that fuck up.
Oh,
dummies.
Who were proud of that
be from America.
Like they did something to one to one
thing.
We proud to be from America because we
have an agreement that we're America and
we're not conscious.
We all get together and we fucking
strive.
We try to make the best shit and be
proud of that,
but to make it seem like you're great
because you're American when you were
just fucking born in a lucky spot,
like that's ridiculous.
That's fucking bullshit.
It's not your country.
Yeah,
exactly.
You if you're lucky enough to be born
anywhere you're at,
you should be proud of of where you're
at,
but part of being,
having pride in that is by being a
fucking good example of a human being
and representing that culture to its
fullest.
That's it.
Not being proud
that you're from a fucking city.
Stupid.
No,
that's ridiculous.
Be Proud.
Be Proud of your own personal control
over your character
and your contribution to hew to your
community.
Your community is to be a fucking
involve yourself.
That's the big problem is,
you know I've said this over and over
again,
is that the biggest resource in the
world,
his children,
children will become the adults of the
future obviously,
and the more access to information and
character building exercises and the
more we can make them great,
the better off the future's going to be
for everybody of course,
but that's the most neglected aspect of
this world.
Exactly.
I mean,
how many people are just out there
popping kids out?
They don't have the education or the
money to support.
I mean,
they don't even,
to me,
I look at it is they don't understand
how difficult and how important raising
a child.
There's also a disconnect in what we
call culture.
There's a disconnect in a society
because the society started out where
everybody had to stick together because
you go on a hunting parties and you
know,
you'd be growing food or taking care of
babies and they were to be collective
collection collectives where,
uh,
you know,
everybody would pile in their food.
Everybody had to stay alive.
Everybody had to do their own job.
Everybody knew everybody encountered on
everybody.
But it got to a point where there wasn't
50 people anymore.
Now,
now you have walls and now there's a
thousand,
now there's 2000.
Now you don't even know these fucking
people.
So that,
that this disconnect is in place where
you have all these people that are
supposed to be like your comrades and
your brothers and sisters,
but you don't even fucking know them.
You know?
And then it get.
That's when you get to a city and that's
when you get to a country.
And that's where America is.
It's this weird
then now look at the way that technology
has influenced our disconnect from each
other.
You're buried in your phone everyday of
every,
of every second of every hour.
These people,
you're not talking to anybody in line
and you're not actually conversing with
the people that provide the services
that you,
that you're supposed to go to in life.
Like the postman,
the,
the person with the supermarket.
You're not converting.
You're just like,
hey,
swipe card.
Do whatever you got back.
You know,
ironically,
it's also connecting countries,
Internet connects countries and
disconnects people.
It does.
The thing is is that the internet can be
used for so much good and it can also be
a crutch to turn you into a shitty
completely non community based.
You think that you're getting the same
thing by being on facebook or twitter
and all this and that.
All of sudden that you're interacting
with people,
you are interacting with people,
but that is not the way humanity works.
In fact,
I was reading a thing about how being a
misanthrope like deliberately not
interacting with society on a regular
basis can be worse than being an
alcoholic for your,
for your body and your health.
Like just simply not interacting with
other people.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
I mean it's just,
you're,
you're dwelling on it
negative energy and you're not getting
any positive warm from humans,
which is like one of the most satisfying
things a person can get as well.
Like
love from other people.
Yeah.
You see somebody write something nice to
you online,
all that.
That's cool.
If you have an a one on one
conversation,
look somebody in the eye and they say,
you know what,
I really respect you for the person that
you and I,
I,
I'm really proud to know you.
That as a way different effect on some.
Same as like people want to send text
messages about important as shit.
Like oh,
sorry about this.
Oh,
and you know,
dog eat whatever or something.
Or a are like,
oh,
did you hear that a so and so.
It just died like,
fuck,
give me at least a phone call.
Like a text is not.
I mean,
well that's a cheap way out.
It is a cheap way because you really,
you're,
it's like,
oh,
I want to break up with you with even a
phone call or do anything show up and
somebody wants to break up with you and
sends you a text message.
You Got off light.
I guess.
So I want to talk to you.
I've gotten a phone call break up.
Oh yeah.
That was actually,
that one was,
that was,
that was really fucked up.
I'm like,
oh man.
Well it was to me also because I'm like,
aren't you?
Weren't you?
Weren't we supposed to be like best
friends before all this shit together,
Josh?
Pardon?
Shitty.
God.
Can't even look me in the face and be
like,
Hey,
what's up?
It's over.
Bitch.
Can't fuck me.
No Mall is heading in that direction.
And you stay right there.
My own boat and a bonanza.
This vagina right out.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
the,
the lack of development of,
uh,
of human beings like where they're
tested and where they have to develop
character that's like one of the big,
like one of the most disappointing
aspects of our society and our culture
is that we've never figured out a way to
cultivate people correctly that way we
can do it.
That's the question.
We have plenty of money and plenty of
resources to do things.
It's,
and it can just start from the smallest
thing in the house with chores to,
to just,
you know,
just being stern in your word and,
and leading by example.
I mean the opportunity to give children
those things to help develop them,
male or female,
you know,
exist every single day and they're
completely at our fingertips.
If we want to choose to participate and
taking that kind of responsibility for
bringing this child into the world and
trying to raise them to be a,
uh,
an awesome human being,
an uh,
uh,
contributing important part of society
and helping show by example what a good
person is.
You know,
the drop that starts the ripples.
That's super important.
Well it is and some people,
they obviously they take on that task
when they're just trying to get some
pussy,
let people,
all of a sudden they're there,
they're there in this situation and they
try to make due and they fuck up and
they,
you know,
they really don't have their own shit
together.
But I think as a society what we got,
there's a real problem in that we,
we haven't really addressed how to
properly,
properly make use of our,
our young people.
I think it's beautiful to have freedom.
It's beautiful to have the ability to
choose whatever occupation you want and
speed.
But I think that like the steps that you
go from being a young man,
living with your parents to being in
college,
to being independent there,
they're so obscure and massive.
It's so like,
am I really am out of.
Am I out here now?
Okay,
now I've got to get an apartment and
what do I do now?
While you've got to make sure you got a
good job,
but a good.
Okay,
I'm good.
You could do that.
How do you get the good?
Yeah,
right.
Go to college,
you go to college,
you
spend on it.
It's like actually,
you know,
I mean there's still this huge myth that
you need to go get a four year degree in
dollar ship will,
you know,
not every four year degree is actually
worth the fucking $50,000.
You just put yourself in debt.
Like sometimes you're actually doing a
disservice to yourself and putting
yourself behind the.
You can be just another college
graduate,
work in a fucking shit job that can't,
can barely pay off their loans.
You got to realize what,
what is it,
where is it worth putting that money
towards?
You know what I tell people all the time
that are just sort of,
you know,
unsettled,
whatever.
Even,
you know,
parents are kids,
we're thinking about moving them along
in the next step.
They're graduating to go sending a fuck,
you know,
figure out,
get a,
you know,
he probably isn't.
He or she isn't going to really know
what they want to do yet.
Likely.
But if they have an idea,
find the,
uh,
the university or whatever school that
at some point they're going to need to
be at and then find the appropriate
junior community college that,
that transfer as well into that fucking
dude and the dude that because you need
to get in there and get your shit done.
Books,
education.
I mean,
if you really want to be true about it,
you don't have to go to college to learn
anything.
You can fucking read a book.
You can teach yourself and even with
like the Internet like you're talking
about,
there is so much information and
knowledge out there that a person can
process.
Now of course,
having one on,
well you don't ever get that
necessarily,
but having human interaction to help
guide you upon this with their own
experience is invaluable.
But the actual knowledge of the APP,
the actual process of just gathering
knowledge and getting understandings
that,
fuck man,
you think you could become a lawyer by
going to a library.
The actual process of gathering
knowledge for sure is,
uh,
you know,
it's much easier now than it's ever been
before.
The real problem is that people don't
have good guidelines as far as behavior,
as far as getting things done,
and as far as positive thinking,
yes.
One of the things that has been a side
effect of this podcast are completely
unintended and we never saw it coming.
Was that all these fucking people are.
I meet them after shows.
He changed my life.
I lost 100 pounds.
I drink Kale shakes every morning.
I work out everyday.
I started Jujitsu.
It's like thousands of fucking people.
It's like,
and what they say is that almost to a
man,
it's like I never had anybody around me
that was talking the right way is that
it wasn't me.
It's not that I didn't have potential.
It's not that I have no,
but nobody that motivated me and then
all of a sudden someone did and now what
are you doing?
Are you sleeping over there?
Dude,
it's not me.
Is that you're snoring?
No.
You sleeping.
Sleeping.
No.
That wasn't you.
I think there's not enough.
It wasn't.
You know somebody who is breathing and
it doesn't like
it wasn't him.
Oh my God,
he was sleep.
I swear to God.
That sounds really familiar to a lot of
women.
I've called.
Is that what you do?
It's,
it's my opening.
Tell you what you're wearing.
If you like that.
If you go,
Hey,
what are you wearing?
Crazy bitch.
Then they tell you a dirty whore bars.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
we all have our preferences.
That's when they get kicked,
punched her with you.
Get it.
You know what?
It's just like I said,
you,
you wanna.
Do you want people to be a certain way?
You want to make a difference in the
world?
Start with yourself and it goes from
there.
We'll start with you.
So lead.
Give an example that other people can
follow.
Just like the examples that you
followed.
I mean everybody is where they are
because they learn for someone greater
than them.
Almost everybody to a person.
Learn from somebody.
When I have some of the men that have
been formative in developing who I am as
a man in life,
and I tell people some of the stories
that came to,
you know,
to,
to have these people in my life and
some,
and there's some folks,
especially a lot of these,
these,
these men nowadays that are,
and I'm not even to speak about women
because women and men are,
they have totally different mindsets in
the way that they develop.
And uh,
you can,
they're apples and oranges,
but the men,
you,
the men and women,
a different dude.
Oh my God,
man from Mars were women.
I know I'm from Mars.
Are they from Uranus as a save a
warrior,
you know,
as the god of war and death and blood
and fire and all that.
She just needed a hug.
Yeah,
in a handy,
but a start from there,
uh,
these,
these men will look at me that way.
Underdeveloped in terms of trying to,
to,
to have that well rounded understanding
of,
of being a man.
You know,
I haven't the all the,
all the facets covered and I'll tell him
these stories about some of the people
that,
that are major to making me the man I am
and they're like,
like their eyes get huge dinner place
and they can't believe that they're
like,
that sounds terrible.
That's fucking horrible.
That's how like,
you know what's not actually that bad.
All right.
You know,
and I'm wouldn't change any of it
because it made me the kind of person
that I am the day and I like who I am
and,
and some of these people were hard as
fuck.
There's been some people in the past
that were hard as fuck that farmer
Burns' character who used to hang
himself.
Oh yeah.
By his own hang himself from his neck
and just stand there.
People Watch this guy used to drop.
He didn't just use to hang himself.
He used to drop like,
I don't know how.
I don't know how many feet it was.
I mean,
it wasn't,
it wasn't just let me put this around.
Okay,
I'm ready.
Go.
No,
he would drop and catch yourself with
his fucking neck.
And neck,
giant neck,
these guys used to wrestle a back in the
day doing all the catches,
catch can stuff or just any type of
wrestling and have nice,
wonderful spongy mats.
And if you did have any sort of matte
substance that you could use a,
it was probably someplace that was quite
affluent so you know what they wrestling
on ground grass,
rug,
carpet type shit,
you know,
I mean that's a snake pit in,
in England.
They used to wrestle on a carpet
throwing each other.
Jesus,
Jesus Christ.
But that was it.
Pick out a famous catch.
There's a,
there's a couple different schools of
submission style,
a grappling and one of the earliest ones
in America,
the called catch wrestling or catch as
catch can.
And um,
it was,
it was real professional wrestling at
one point in time,
unlike theatrical professional
wrestling,
which is like entertainment.
They used to,
they used to go out and then you can pin
a guy or you can submit them.
It could be,
it could be either one.
And there's a lot of gangster fucking
holds that I learned from Sylvia Momenta
who was a black belt in a gene labell oh
yeah.
Gina Bell loves all that Shit.
So sylvio,
uh,
he was always like pig and all these
crazy net cranks and all,
all these different things that like,
I'm like,
why aren't these in Jujitsu?
Cause.
But they are.
Some guys use them.
Do you see,
did you see Damien Maia has victory over
Rick Story?
Uh,
no I didn't.
He submitted them in the first round,
but he got his back.
He couldn't get a rear naked and so he
turned it into a net cranking.
Sure.
Fuck the shit out of luck.
Yeah.
Oh,
it was a terrible angle.
Like it was like instant tap ones.
Like your head's gonna fly off.
Sure enough,
I mean wrestling is wrestling match and,
and it's all over the world and people
are styles that have developed,
you know,
Jujitsu is the way it is for the most
part because of the rules of the sport,
of Jujitsu.
Because you know,
often sport will predicate how your
training will be developed because you
want to be the best within this
confinement.
Uh,
but that doesn't,
that's not to say that you can't expand
upon anything with the human body.
If you want to be a dynamic,
be as dynamic as you want to,
you know,
the jkd Bruce Lee's philosophy,
eat the meat and spit out the bone.
I mean,
there's no reason anybody can't do that
for themselves.
But you know,
what's his name?
Um,
Shannon,
who's the dude?
Jake Shannon,
Shannon.
Shannon is a,
a great historian when it comes to just
the traps.
Awesome dude all around me when it comes
to,
uh,
you know,
even political stuff and cultural stuff
and he's a brilliant dude and uh,
the shit that he puts out there in the
world as a whole,
not just the catch stuff is amazing
shit.
Yeah,
I agree.
He's a really good dude.
Great.
Historically
he really loves like the history of
catch wrestling and because of him and
he's put out books and dvds and shit,
but some of the photos that he's found,
it's amazing like the techniques that
they had that they were using,
like triangles that were using,
they were using half guard.
They're using the lockdown from half
guard.
There were sweeping guys with these
positions.
Are we using all these different good
teams arm in game.
The first
time I saw the lockdown Sushi Osaka was
doing it to us in an AMC back in the day
and he used it as the submission
version.
So you get lined up on a half guard,
you'd throw the lockdown on and you
would extend and you basically you're
putting like a calf crank on somebody.
And so that's how I first,
this was back in like 2001 if you count
sideways on it,
it's like a heel hook too.
So that's how I learned it as like a,
like a tricky little submission and
close Daca was full of them,
you know,
tk.
Yeah.
And so that's what I first found out
about lockdown.
And then,
um,
and then I saw Eddie,
you know,
he came across and he used it as a,
as a positional to keep him for,
for using his bottom game in terms of
his reverses reversals and setting up,
you know,
isolating that leg to use it later into
different applications.
But it just goes to show you,
you can do fucking things a million
ways.
And then I remember Billy Robinson,
who is from the snake pit,
uh,
in England where that whole term,
like those,
uh,
he's a billy Robinson,
is a,
uh,
he's from Wigan and in Wigan,
that's what they came up with.
The term catches catch,
can get it any way you can.
And uh,
billy,
uh,
which I also refer to my love life.
Um,
then,
uh,
they had,
the snake pit over there and billy Riley
started this place and just only the
toughest of the tough,
these fucking coal miners,
these,
these gnarly dudes wrestling on
hardwood.
Well,
here's another sport that they used to
do over there called [inaudible].
And what they would do is they would,
yeah,
it doesn't.
Yeah.
It doesn't involve kitty cats,
unfortunately.
What it involves is them putting on,
they have these boots with studs on them
on the bottom and it would kick each
other in the shin.
Oh,
get the fuck out of here.
Not just like freeform,
but back and forth.
I go.
You go until somebody quit?
Yes.
How big of the spikes.
Okay.
I don't know too big.
Obviously.
It's always too big.
It's just like this.
Is there any photos of this shit?
I believe so.
Go ahead and look it up.
But a Peri Peri P,
P U R R A,
P U R R I n g I believe.
Hurrying violence taking shins.
England.
Uh,
so anyways,
just with England,
was it?
There was no policy over there.
I'm just exhausted that opportunity and
know snort and too much coal,
I guess makes you want to kick each
other in the shins,
but we're not so polite today.
Sure enough.
Yeah.
Uh,
but uh,
uh,
the only time I remember being in a town
with the UFC were over in England and
the only time I remember where,
or the fighters were out trying to go
grab shit to eat and do whatever.
And people are constantly like,
Hey,
fuck,
you might want to fucking go like,
Whoa,
dude,
are you kidding me?
It was just London.
Yes.
Just over nothing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Thank you.
Looking at me funny.
We'll fucking knock you out.
Right?
Well some improper proper go out and
looking for that shit.
Sure enough.
But I just remember people coming back
to the hotel over and over again,
be like,
Jesus Christ,
man.
Everyone's trying to like the hardest
shit trying to fight everyone.
Was this the uh,
Tito Ortiz,
Lee Marie days.
Oh yes.
So this was actually before mma had
really made its way to Ingraham and
isn't that interesting?
They didn't really give a shit like who
any of these,
you know,
American blocks where they want to fight
them.
But it's funny,
there's a before and I'm a keen there
because now that mma is there,
the attitude is kind of different.
Still.
Plenty of Brits,
they'll just want to slug you up.
But uh,
so,
so these guys,
you know,
these cats,
wrestlers,
you know,
they're going out there.
And so billy Robinson who trained at the
snake pit,
he's a catch wrestler.
And an amateur wrestler and I remember,
uh,
he's doing a little seminar out in Santa
Monica and he's showing this dropdown,
sort of this,
this leg hook,
single leg,
and it turned,
you know,
you drop to a hip and then you come back
up.
And I'm like,
just so you know,
billy right now,
there's this Jujitsu guy called Marcello
Garcia and that's like his number one
into everything he fucking does right
now.
And not crazy.
Even though you've never trained
Jujitsu,
you've never seen Marcello and trust me,
billy Robinson had never seen or heard
of Marcello Garcia.
It's just moves.
Yeah.
Well Marcello's technique is fairly
basic.
It's just that he had hit it so well,
like the arm drag to the back.
It was pretty,
pretty standard the way he did it with.
So is this,
it is this powering.
Oh my God,
a very good photos.
Is this real?
These motherfuckers still do this shit.
I don't see any spikes.
Did they give up on the spikes?
Oh No,
they have spikes around their ankles.
Do you see?
I'm talking about she's.
When there's not enough vagina around,
you start doing really stupid shit.
It.
Trust me.
I grew up in Boston.
I know what's up.
So,
uh,
oh,
there we go.
So,
uh,
this guy grew up doing that as well when
they weren't.
I don't think Billy Robinson was doing
any permanent.
I think it was smarter than that,
but it's just the fact that,
you know,
moves are moves and you know,
he's showing something from one angle
and it's like,
by the way,
you know,
there's a guy doing that right now and
he's winning a world title.
I think it was really interesting when
the Shin Kicking Championships,
Jesus Christ,
this is state,
this is pussy shit.
They're putting hay.
They're packing their shins with,
hey,
this is fake.
Fake.
These frauds,
frauds take these frauds away.
Um,
it was really interesting in mma when
soccer Robert came along because there
was this one style of submissions that
everybody was sort of gravitating
towards are a lot of people gravitate
towards,
which is Brazilian Jujitsu.
And then there's this Japanese dude who
had this really kind of Funky,
different sort of style,
did like similar techniques but kinda
had his own little flair to it.
And it turned out he had actually been
trained in catch wrestling that he was a
robinson.
Yeah,
that's an amazing story.
The Sakharova for people weren't really
fans of MMA.
They'll never going to appreciate how,
what a bad motherfucker Kazoo.
She soccer.
Let me tell you some Sakharova shit
about,
you know,
I know how bad ass he is.
You know,
how bad ass he is a lot.
There are plenty of,
uh,
of serious mma fans that know how legit
Sakharova was and how much of a,
uh,
of a,
of like a,
just a character got like a sprung
fucking cat on the ground.
Like just able to,
to,
to bound the,
to any positioning and come get his
stuff,
you know,
uh,
back in the day when he was going
through the system and at the UWF during
the shoot style progressing stuff where
they would sometimes mixing shoots and
works on the same deal.
And a shoot for folks who don't know
what it means really full on fight,
but these were all predetermined bright
and these are all under professional
wrestling rules.
They had this last point thing with the
rope escapes and getting suplex and
knocked down and whatever.
But uh,
you know,
back in the day,
not only did a Toccata used to beat them
up because Takata used to be a legit,
like fucking.
I had a hellacious kick.
He was a good athlete and he could
fight.
But tamra used to abuse the Shit Outta
Sakharova all the time.
There was a few times where they'd go,
they'd the ring in professional
wrestling.
They would go legit and fucking Tamar
would own him.
Like Tamra was the man.
So what happened?
How did Sakharova he graduated,
man,
he grew up.
He got better.
Yeah,
of course.
And fight the first UFC in Japan when he
fought Kona.
So Vera and they,
uh,
they stopped prematurely and he was
like,
what the fuck?
And so they started a back up again
later on,
later on that night,
they didn't fight again.
It was craziness.
It was like,
boy,
just the emotional rollercoaster.
They must've been under.
He didn't just beat him.
He went out and tapped him tap conan.
So Vera,
which had never been done before.
No one had seen a Brazilian jujitsu
black belt get tapped yet.
It was like the new thing.
I was like maybe,
maybe someone had,
I think maybe I'm John Lewis and uh,
Andre Pinera,
I think maybe pet nera said tap John
Lewis.
Did he tap him?
Did he know he didn't tap me soccer.
Kicked him.
Oh,
did Sata was on his back and Eris like
slapped why his right leg and came
around with his left and soccer kicked
them while Sato is an open garden.
Was so was.
Who was the first place in Japan to
black belt to get tapped?
Because it might've been,
it might've been.
It was like,
it was like,
it was the most high profile one,
that's for sure.
Well then,
uh,
was that,
that was before Maurice Fought Conan?
No,
after,
after.
Yeah.
Maurice had already known that going in
and out,
but you know,
a key box or knocking somebody out
that's,
you know,
kind of a given.
But the idea of a Jujitsu guy lose,
especially to a non Jujitsu fighter.
Yeah,
no,
they know what the contributor.
And I used to get that all the time at
AMC and people would be like introducing
folks,
what's your belt?
Uh,
I don't have a belt.
Oh,
what do you do for grappling?
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
we train here,
we do catch wrestling with,
do they?
Oh,
okay,
okay.
And then we'd roll on it,
fucking annihilate them and they'd get
so pissed and upset and phony Baloney.
Unfortunately there are.
But you know,
that's a wonderful aspect of humanity if
you've got the ability to,
uh,
to uh,
to bring truth into the world and be
honest about shit and you know,
with all the faults and,
and also great things about it.
Most human beings instinct is to go out
there and just lie the fuck out of it
and just make excuses changed shit
around because you know,
it's not good enough to just to have
things exist and have it be true.
No,
we have to go ahead.
And I mean,
especially shit like religion,
politics,
it's just,
Oh,
let's make a book and call out the word
of God.
So therefore you can't fucking argue
against it.
Anything that happens.
He said,
well,
the word of God,
the word of God with garbage and then,
uh,
but essentially have a book that's
compiled of other books.
The end,
you decided to leave other random shit
out just because,
and then,
you know,
it's gone through the hands of all these
other people and all their other agendas
from Jujitsu.
It's because the basic idea of it was a
human beings all throughout
civilization.
A full of shit when they flying line
for,
you know,
obscuring the truth.
There's a lot of guys that uh,
don't have belts that are like,
like super high level.
Matt Hughes,
Chris Lidell,
Chris,
we said Chris was a Brazilian jujitsu
black belt.
But apparently that was like even given
it to us press sheets,
Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu,
blackbelt,
Chris Lidell.
No,
he doesn't have any belt.
Probably not.
No.
He trained with those.
Uh,
speaking of a bunch of cats wrestlers
that integrated fighting academy.
Where,
where was that?
That was out in Indianapolis.
That was Jason.
God sees place.
You're such an interesting case.
Knew because you were there like during
the dark days,
like you were there,
like,
like you were there when there was no
regulation,
you were there when you were allowed to
wear shoes,
you know,
like kicking,
stopping and that you're still here when
it's not far.
The difference is that,
you know,
as I've developed as an athlete over the
years,
but the biggest thing is I developed my
skills.
So I'm not.
Most of these fighters and you know,
I'll,
I'll say this and I'll say it publicly,
they have most of these fighters that go
through the system,
let's say they get good enough that they
get,
let's say,
to get in the UFC and we'll just use the
UFC is the,
as the,
as the standard example,
excuse me.
So what they do is,
uh,
they get to a certain point and they get
to enough a skill wise and then they
just improve their athleticism to such a
degree with.
They'll get into the UFC,
let's say,
and let's say they're successful,
they probably have about a two to three
year window if they're good enough to be
like a,
to a,
to get a title or be a title contender.
If they're that good,
they got about two or three years at
which they could potentially get a title
or fight for a title.
And after that then they're never been
declined.
And then they might still be successful
enough to be still a viable,
a fighter in the UFC.
But even that lasts about is about only
is about as much as five years.
And after that throw them out because
they're done.
Their athleticism has dropped enough
that they don't have the skills to back
it up anymore.
Most of these fighters just out athlete
the other fighter for the most part.
And,
uh,
they even did a big statistic about
fight careers and the,
once you get to seven years,
the dropoff for success is astronomical
and the idea of people going 10 years or
15 years like myself,
unreal,
like it's almost unheard of.
And uh,
well not only that,
but you go from age 20 to age 35,
19 to 35,
19 was my first time against a pro
and at 35,
you're still amongst the top
heavyweights in the world.
I could be any of those motherfuckers
out there walking the earth right now.
If you had to,
would you,
I mean,
if you had to retire for any reason,
would you start coaching because I think
you would have a lot to offer.
I think you're,
you have,
um,
just the fact that you've gotten through
15 years at a very high level,
you know,
I mean from your time and pride to
today.
I mean,
that's a,
it's a lot of God damn competition
against very high level guys.
You didn't have a lot of shit that you
could teach kids that could cut out.
Like you see like a lot of people that
are being coached and being coached by
people that don't have nearly the kind
of experience that you have and you see
some mistakes they're making with young
talent.
Sure,
I do.
I see a lot of mistakes.
And in terms of coaching,
it's not just even about technique
necessarily.
A lot of it is they,
they create a system and they think that
everybody has to fit within that system
and that there is no,
there is no wavering from that system.
And the thing is not any.
Everybody is different.
Everybody's an individual and everybody
needs to be coached differently.
I've had a and I have coached through
the years and I've,
I've coached people,
the world championship fights,
I've coached people to the world titles.
I've had a,
I think I've had more women at one time
ranked in the top 10 and some,
most of them ranked in the top five of
the world and their respective way
classes than any other coach.
And then the baby food Fuji was making
Fuji Jenelle Marquez.
Shana Bassler.
I've,
we're going to hit told me,
you know,
uh,
let's see.
Uh,
so are you,
are you want you,
that what you want to do when you start
fighting?
No,
no,
because I was thinking that you didn't
know a real shame because there's not a
lot of guys who are fighters but have
also taken the time to really sort of
intellectually breakdown the properties
of creating a fight.
I don't want to be a coach like that.
I just don't because if I'm going to be
a coach,
think of it more as like an old school
boxing coach or maybe one of these old
catch coaches where you only really,
okay.
Someone proves to you enough that
they're worth giving that kind of time
and information.
I don't just look at it as well,
I'm just going to show you some move.
By the way,
this move came from this coach came from
that coach came.
Do you know how many hundreds of years
of development came behind this?
Do you know how difficult it was for
someone to the original person down the
line to get this thing to me with the
shit that they had to go through and to
live their life and to harness these
techniques and give them to me.
These things are precious,
so I understand that,
but when I see a guy like you and I see,
you know,
you have 35 years of age.
I mean totally respectfully and
honestly.
I mean,
what do you got five years left?
Ten years left.
If you're,
I guess Randy coture style,
I'm done.
You never know.
You know what I mean?
With today it was nutrition and training
methods.
Who knows with skill,
but when,
if a guy like you got a hold of John
Jones type character,
you could take a motherfucker to the
next level.
You know what I mean?
If you,
if you really started like approaching.
Okay,
Jon Jones,
is it an anomaly?
He's just,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He,
anybody could make him good.
Yes and no.
Yes,
and without a doubt.
Mike Winkeljohn has done some amazing
things.
Without a doubt.
He's brilliant.
Without a doubt,
John is a prodigy.
John is a.
he's a very intense,
powerful human being.
John Jones,
besides his physicality,
which is obviously very gifted,
his mind is very powerful and I think he
would be great that he would figure it
out watching other people,
no matter who was coaching,
he,
he's the kind of guy that's going to
excel no matter what.
But having a guy like Winkeljohn who's a
brilliant striking code,
they really different being
somebody that like,
you know,
taking that middle of the pack guy and
that one and developing them into a
world champion that's always going to
get that.
You'll never be.
But it depends.
I mean,
and that's what I'm saying is I'm not
going to.
Because there's a lot going on there,
right?
I'm not talking necessarily about who I
would coach.
You just be like the ones that just
shine as.
No,
I want to coach.
I would coach a person that I feel
personality,
integrity,
character mentality as well as
physicality all matches what I think is
worth investing the time into.
So you would do that,
but they would have to.
He'd be like special people came onto up
on the mountain top when you're alone
fucking chopping wood and then you will
make them like fences and shit.
Right?
You know,
I wax on carbon carbon.
Some ruins into their body.
So you're going to do it like we go
chapel really style still works,
still works with Mac Danzig.
He works at a few people,
but he's not the man.
I,
that's one of those guys I have a shit
ton of respect for.
I do have one.
I think Ricoh is um,
often,
you know,
he's so unknown to so many of these guys
out there that claim to be mma
aficionados.
They just don't know their ass from a
hole in the wall.
It really don't know.
And that there's people out there like
Rico who's wrestling is fantastic.
Who's mind to fighting is great.
Who,
whose attitude is,
you know,
you want to get in there with this and
this is what you want to do.
I can,
I can help you with that and I can show
you if you're going to fucking slack
off,
fuck around,
whatever you think you know better than
all,
then fuck you.
Then take off.
I don't need you.
And he smokes weed all day or day or a
day to day and he will choke you all
day.
Fuck your shit.
And I really respect Mac Danzig a lot.
I like Mac as a human being.
I think he's really,
he's just,
he's just a solid dude.
I love that guy.
I know he's grumpy,
but he's just because he's smart as
fuck.
He's always super cool to me too.
He just has a low tolerance for dummies.
I still do.
I really do.
I can't stand fucking idiots.
But Matt speaks so highly of Rico,
you know,
and what Rico is done and helping as he
should.
Yeah.
But I just,
as a coach,
there's so much investment
goes into that and that it's not
something I'm,
I'm not saying I won't coach.
Uh,
and if the availability is there a and
the possibility is there,
but I just,
I got a lot of Shit,
you know what I'm done with fighting a
whenever that day comes,
which is going to suck in its own right.
But uh,
I got other shit I can do with my life.
Other things I'm trying to accomplish,
you know?
Um,
I mean a male model.
Well,
little underwear modeling perhaps a
little bit,
little bit.
I mean we got to do a lot of padding,
but I think we can make the most of it.
I mean,
prosthetics are pretty impressive.
Don't go prosthetic,
but the little dick,
but a big smile.
Oh man,
fuck it.
Little Little Chubby.
A little turtle or let it swing.
It gives a fuck.
You're Josh Barnett.
Still Suck it.
But the easier so much just you ever
watch a porn when the guys get a little
dick and this girl's like licking his
bowl.
She's already in so happy about it.
It's like an easy,
easy deal and it's just,
it's a,
it's more like convenience.
Yeah.
The guy with the little deck,
like maybe there's a benefit to that,
like the sheer,
now she's deep throat and him and it's,
you know,
it's not that impressive,
but it
looks like he's having a good time and,
and she's like,
this is,
this is not straining.
Stressing me.
One of dudes with John Hancock's feel
more pleasure because there's more
pleasure.
Just more skin,
more,
more skin is getting close.
Like if a girl's giving you a blow job
and she goes in deeper,
it feels better than if she's shallow.
Right?
It's definitely something that's mental
commodities.
Even chick begin feeling it hit the back
and she keep going.
So you're like,
oh wow.
We just.
The idea of it alone,
someone's willing to suck on your
tablet.
I only half mast right now.
I'm,
I'm ready.
If you had the girl like where you go so
far and they start like puking,
like the stomach acid all over your
mouth during the porn movies today in
the wrong girls.
How am I started up?
They got to relax yourself,
I guess to get these girls to throw up
on your Dick.
That's like bio and stuff.
It feels good actually.
It's awesome.
What if they don't?
Uh,
if those girls don't,
they don't watch their diet and they're
probably like all anorexic and signs of
like weird cat food all over it.
Fuck,
are you talking about cat food?
Maybe I'd eight different girls.
And you do,
but everybody does a who hates cats.
He dates cats day cats,
cat food.
There are so finicky.
You did it again.
It took it to a bad place.
Where,
uh,
where were we going with this before we
got on a blow jobs and small Dicks,
I don't know.
Terrible places.
One of the things that you wanted to
talk about when you,
you,
uh,
contacted me about coming on the podcast
is all this craziness that's going on
with all these school shootings and
school shootings.
It was the,
uh,
the Oregon shooting.
I guess that one was in a mall and all
this shit.
Yeah.
Well,
and the interesting thing about the
mall,
one that's coming out now is that he was
confronted by an armed civilian and
that's when he shot himself.
And that's not something that's being
talked about very much.
Why would they?
That doesn't work with the agenda at
hand of why.
And you know,
that's,
that's hard of a problem,
right?
A huge problem is that we've got media
that wants to just create knee jerk
reactions and emotional responses.
They don't care about trying to deliver
a whole unbiased story.
They've each got an agenda to try and
put a rift in the populace at general at
large.
And that's fucking irresponsible and is
terrible.
I was listening to a,
something that would come on about a,
it was either MSNBC or CNN and after the
horrible Sandy Hook,
tragedy,
uh,
one of the teachers,
boyfriends have a year.
They found him and started giving their
full interview on.
I'm just going,
why I don't want to.
This is completely one.
It's just giving more prudent credence
to,
hey,
you want to do something crazy and be
fucking famous forever.
Here's more publicity for you.
It's like,
well,
you didn't have anything else better to
do than talk to a guy.
Oh,
I knew her for a year.
And like you were some guy,
some guy for a year,
it wasn't even crying,
like you didn't even miss her.
It was like,
it was no big deal and he was on CNN.
Maybe he really did fucking,
you know,
he was super torn up about it,
whatever.
But it doesn't fucking matter because
why are you on TV?
Why is the news finding that to be
important to talk about?
Why shouldn't we be talking about
something more important?
Like why is our culture devolving in
such a way that people are acting in
such manner,
whether they're shooting people or
fucking stabbing them or robbing them or
car jacking him and taking them back to
a place and raping and torturing him.
Like what the fuck is going on?
Why?
Why is humanity at large doing this kind
of shit?
And then the other thing,
so another channel.
I'm sitting here and I just hear it
coming into the ears and I hear they're
talking about how some Republican,
his,
you know,
he keeps,
he throws out the word assault weapon
like 17 times.
Uh,
every,
every fucking statement he's got to
make.
He's really trying to pin,
you know,
pound something home with his lingo and
then there's a,
the reporter goes on after talking about
this guy who was gonna,
you know,
probably working towards creating bills
about this ship will,
she'll probably be back ended with all
kinds of shit that have nothing to do
with it,
which they always do,
always,
you know,
it's just fucking absolute tantamount
lying.
It's absolute fucking lying.
Irresponsible.
And it should be absolutely anil loud.
So.
So after that,
this,
this reporter goes on about,
you know,
something about,
people go and makes an offhand comment
about people going to gun shows and just
not just willy nilly buying firearms and
in that,
just like,
I just couldn't fucking take it anymore.
Didn't Bruno true.
Proven.
That's true.
Didn't he go to a gun store as a gay
character?
Didn't?
Uh,
I dunno,
I haven't seen the movie.
I mean,
but here's the deal.
I guess it wasn't in Bruno was on the
show.
I,
uh,
you know,
who knows what they're doing on shows
the people you can people have sold
potentially.
I could see it a fucking shady stuff.
Yeah.
But people will sell guns,
not at gun shows.
They get some other way.
I mean,
fuck.
So here's the deal.
I am a lifelong hobbyist when it comes
to firearms.
I,
it was,
uh,
it was something I inherited from my dad
who a big time hobbyist.
And when I say hobbyist,
I reload.
Meaning I make my own ammunition.
Like I buy bullets have different
weights and shapes and sizes.
I buy different types of powders to have
to burn at different rates.
And you know,
all this shit is very.
Exactly.
I Buy Bras and primers and I match all
this shit up based on recipes through,
uh,
the,
the ammunition manufacturers that sell
this stuff through my dad's own research
on certain,
you know.
And the thing is every firearm that
you're doing this for is entirely
different.
You could have three,
19,
11,
45,
all the same barrel length,
all the same manufacturer,
but they're not all going to shoot the
same.
Not exactly in one load is going to
shoot different than the other other.
Some bullet weights depending on barrel
length.
The amount of rifling has gone nuts.
I'm a gun nut.
Okay.
And uh,
you know,
I grew up not only with that but my dad
inherited from,
from people in his life,
the hobby of,
of target shooting and,
and,
you know,
gun smithing and creating your and just
being a,
just a nerd about guns.
Like I'm a nerd about cars,
but he was a hunter.
And when,
when,
uh,
and he was growing up,
that's what you did.
He grew up in the fucking woods of,
of southwestern Washington.
Uh,
he was a logger from as early as he
could.
He worked in paper mills.
He's been in the forest all his whole
fucking life almost.
And so hunting,
fishing game,
all that kind of stuff.
And uh,
you know,
I've been out there in the woods with
him since I was a kid going hunting and
catch,
you know,
getting animals,
cleaning them,
dressing.
I'm going through the whole process and
I can tell you one thing.
Fucking being a hunter and being
somebody that had spent so much time in
the wilderness and Anon,
the Anon,
the ocean and boats fishing and all this
made me appreciate nature like a
gazillion times more than I think
anybody that doesn't necessarily.
I think nature is something that is
overlooked huge and I don't think we as
humans sometimes really understand the
vastness and the impressiveness of of
mother earth as a general and you know,
being out there in the mountains and
seeing the animals and the uniting when
you're hunting them.
Just being involved in this whole
process and just knowing them and then
taking an animal and going through that
whole process of,
of all the care and responsibility that
comes to to do this correctly and then
serve this meat to other people.
And when,
when my family didn't have money,
when they're broke as fuck.
The animals that my dad had caught help
feed that family that my.
They're all broke living in this little
apartment in north Seattle and no
unexcused.
They go out there with their tags and
they'd get their,
their,
their elk or they get their deer.
They would,
they would catch fish,
they would grouse all the,
you know,
fuck,
that all went onto the table,
you know,
and that was a big part of that,
that growing up for me.
And so I've had gun responsibility.
I've been shooting since I was a kid and
being a responsible parent is why,
uh,
from the get like one guns were always
locked up.
They're always in safes.
I don't know how to get into these
fucking things.
I'm not allowed access to this shit as a
child or even as an 18 year old,
like that ain't happening.
Like I didn't know that the combination
to my dad's gun safe until I was almost
30 years old,
you know what I mean?
And other than that mean if there was a
possibility,
let's say,
and I didn't know because this was never
spoken about,
if there was even the potential that
there was a firearm,
let's say for home defense,
that was somewhere,
let's say in my parents room,
but I didn't know about through the fear
of fucking God,
I wouldn't step in there.
My Dad had me so afraid of fucking with
his shit or anything in their room as a
responsible parent.
That never happened.
I knew fucking way better.
And the idea if I ever,
if he ever found out if I ever laid
hands on a gun that he wasn't around.
Alright,
well you what you're ascribing sounds
like an ideal situation
to grow up and raise someone in an
environment where you teach them firearm
safety and respect for firearms and
appreciation for firearm.
Absolutely.
The real debate is not that though.
The real debate is the fact that if the
guns are out there,
it's not just you and you're responsible
parents that are going to have these
guns.
It's this crazy motherfucker in
Connecticut and is nutty mother that he
killed.
And then took her guns and shot up all
those poor kids.
Absolutely.
That's the where the real issue comes
in.
It's like,
well,
how do you stop that from happening?
Exactly.
And,
and I,
uh,
and through through all this,
and I'm a time spent,
you know,
actually having firearms as a hobby.
I,
uh,
you know,
I ended up working in the industry of
selling firearms and buying them through
a thrift shop and,
uh,
in Washington.
And uh,
I can tell you like everything that went
through that shop,
everything that was ever done all had to
go through the federal program,
the,
the instant criminal,
national,
instant criminal background check
system.
The Knicks and I had to call in every
fucking thing every single time.
And this whole thing was insistent in pr
in,
in the system for a reason.
And I can't say that it's perfect
because I know it ain't,
it's a federal government,
you know,
there's no way that it's perfect.
In fact,
you know,
reading the information on Nick's,
they like to claim that,
uh,
over,
you know,
since uh,
being put in,
in [inaudible] 93,
there's a over 100 million checks in the
last decade leading the morning,
700,000
denials of firearms in the hands of
people that it shouldn't be.
But the problem is that you look at some
of this stuff and what the things that
they might deny you for sometimes
there's the simple issue of I'm a
concealed weapons owner or a permit
holder in Washington,
which means I already had to go through
fingerprinting.
I had to fill out all this paperwork.
I had to go through a process and get
approved to get my concealed weapons
permit.
And uh,
when that meant,
when I went to a gun store,
even the one I worked at a,
if I want to purchase a handgun,
which normally has a waiting period
because I'm a concealed weapons permit
holder and I've already gone through all
these extra checks.
I fill out all the paperwork like
everyone else had.
All gets filed with the serial number of
the gun.
And what I'm purchasing and so on and so
forth and uh,
and I still go through the next check
list like everybody else,
but because there was somebody in
California who had a similar name to
mind every time I would call in with my
social security number of my weapons
license number,
like all this different information and
data for at least three years.
I was always put on a hold with every
firearm I bought.
And even if that included a rifle,
which is normally a same day thing after
nick's all every single time because
they would always see that there's some
stuff in it and they will always in.
The thing about it is the fact that
there's a hold put on that could last
anywhere from,
you know,
three hours they might call back or you
know,
three days.
It wasn't having a whole.
That was,
that ever bothered me whatsoever.
It's like,
okay,
whatever.
It's just that there isn't like why
isn't this not being updated?
Like you're being given very specific
information about me as a person.
So I want my,
you know,
if I'm going to have this database is
going to be used to try and be a
responsible about having firearms,
not in the hands of people that it
shouldn't be.
Why are you not updating this enough to
know that I'm not that fucking guy.
And eventually three years,
two or three years later down the road
it came about and now that's not the
case anymore for me,
far as I know I haven't bought a Po,
a purchase a firearm in a long time.
But uh,
and then when it came to going to gun
shows,
which I've been a member,
I've been going to gun shows since I was
a kid because my dad would go there and
my uncle and you know.
And then even especially when I worked
for the gun shop,
I would go there and help out at shows.
Maybe if we had a table,
a different stuff.
You go to a gun show and even as a
concealed weapons license holder,
I mean anybody that comes to the gun
show,
you pay your admission,
boom,
you can come in if you want to purchase
a firearm and this goes for the
Washington arms collector association
who runs all their gun shows and
Washington.
You have to go and do another line and
fill out and have all your paperwork,
whereas you have the same in every
state.
I'm not sure now I cannot speak for
every state,
but I know that me growing up as a
working and being a part of the
Washington arms collector association
and all that and going to their gun
shows,
uh,
you have to go get nicks checked.
Well that's all well and good man.
But,
and,
and how do you stop letting this kid who
did this in Connecticut?
I mean,
he violated a bunch.
He approached.
He already started leaving the house.
He started off off
by murdering his mom.
Yeah,
that's already,
that's not good.
No,
it's not good.
And why does a guy murder their,
their parents in the first place?
That's the problem.
And the thing is,
is that,
you know,
he,
he went and he chose to use the tool of
firearms to go off and do whatever that
is that he decided to.
And I still can't figure out why the
fuck in the first place.
Did he go to a school and shoot children
of all things,
like I don't understand that,
that rationale.
Like what did it accomplish?
What was the statement?
What was he trying to prove?
I don't know.
There's not to mention there's even
stuff floating about on the Internet
where the dads have not only this,
uh,
the sandy hook killer and the killer
from the Batman movie a shooting both
somehow have something to do with a
banking and financial stuff that has
actually been disproven.
Well,
no,
they're not actually going to go to the
library a scandal as,
as they're trying to say that they're
both going to be at the library hearing,
but they're not.
But yet the Batman shooters dad is
apparently some,
a statistical analysis,
whatever kind of guy that what he does,
he creates these algorithms that are
used in banking.
Did the decipher all this shit.
And figure all this shit out and what it
is,
is that the shit that he creates,
these algorithms,
these mathematical things are the same
things that you use to figure out that
libraries as being is that the library
scandals,
shit,
all the line that's been done in the
rates being so he's involved or maybe
even just on a cursory way in terms of
figuring out the people that are
cheating you with the banks and then the
other guy,
the dad of the sandy hook killer,
he's apparently it works at some
financial institution of some sort and
his division has three people underneath
them that are being indicted for having
being a part of this live worship and
using the falsified a ratings to to
how many people are involved in the or
scandal.
I mean it isn't impossible.
It was just coincidence.
It could be and I'm not,
I'm not.
I'm not sitting there saying that this
all is necessarily related and I,
I'm sure that there is fucked up
parenting.
That you've got kids that are being
medicated to death and who knows what
he's taking because apparently he was
mentally ill and,
and there are drugs out there that they
will give our kids and they will give
people and have them walk the streets
that some of the side effects are
suicidal thoughts,
homicidal act.
I mean it's just ridiculous.
You're jamming all this medication down,
a human being and you expect them to
function within our society like anybody
else.
Well,
the real issue,
um,
the actual numbers,
the,
a citizens' commission on human rights
of CCHR has said that out of the last 14
recent school shootings,
all of them were committed by those
taking or withdrawing from psychiatric
drugs resulting in 109 wounded,
58 killed.
It was also at least 22 international
drug regulatory warnings that have been
issued on psychiatric drugs causing side
effects of mania,
psychosis,
aggression,
hostility,
violence,
and even homicidal.
I,
I think a big part of it is that it's
not everybody you know.
And that's important for a lot of people
that are on that shit,
that it does them good.
It helps them.
But there's a lot of people that can't
drink also,
you know,
there's a lot of people they drink and
they're gone,
you know,
so you see the switch go off and they
become an alcoholic.
The everybody's got a different setup.
And for some people these things are not
good.
And um,
when,
when you're talking about those numbers,
you could.
I've seen people argue and it's really
fascinating,
the people that are like really opposed
to anything that might be fuckery.
You know,
there's a lot of people like,
oh,
there's this,
there's no cars which are just.
So you're talking about people are
fucked up.
Of course people are fucked up on drugs.
It doesn't mean the drugs are causing
them and you don't know that that's a
really good.
But it's a weird thing where chemical
composition of your brain.
But there's this,
this sort of pro science stance that a
lot of people want to take that are
people that think that there's a lot of
people wearing tinfoil hats and looking
for conspiracies and looking for
nonsense and everything.
But man,
they're like the same type of people
that want to downplay the possibility
that any sort of,
um,
vaccinations have been damaging to
children.
Right.
That's,
that's another weird one that people
don't want.
It was weird and address I
think the strongest argument for all of
that as even potential.
And I'm not talking about that.
I wear tinfoil hats or anything like
that,
but something I stated,
you know,
I touched on earlier throughout mankind,
we fucking lie.
We lie and we cheat our,
our populous constantly over and over
and over.
We do it religion,
we do it with our politics.
They constantly,
you know,
you have companies that go and they
deliberately destroy the environment
with their chemicals and their shit and
they know they're doing it and they know
that it's destroying shit and they just
know that they can get away with it and
they just lie.
And then all of a sudden boom there have
somebody comes out of the woodwork and
make them accountable for it.
And then they backtrack and they tell a
whole bunch more lies.
They feed them a couple of goats and
then they keep on doing the same
bullshit and they never have to pay the
price for.
We have all these politicians that go
out there and when they try to feed us
all these lines about how they're,
you know,
they're this,
they're part of that side and this other
side is wrong and vice versa and split
us as a populous and then they go and
they,
they claim all these great things
they're going to do.
You know,
they do nice,
tricky,
Wonderful Shit.
Like,
Hey,
I'm just about to get reelected.
So now.
Yeah,
gay marriage.
Great.
I totally support it.
Why don't you say a four years ago,
you piece of shit.
Yeah.
You piece of shit.
You know,
he wasn't your son cares.
Here's something crazy.
More than one in 10 in the United
States.
Take antidepressants.
Should they be.
How about,
you know,
good question.
I'll tell you something.
I remember having a.
What does that number?
How many is that one in 10 million
people.
So what does that 30 million.
A 3 million I think know 30 million.
Yeah.
$300.
Yeah,
30 million.
That's insane.
It's not 30 million people out there
walking the street,
all the fucking PROZAC,
Xanax to whatever up.
And I remember,
I remember going through a really
fucking bad breakup not that long ago
and just fucking dying and having
anxiety for the first time.
I've never had that shit.
I've got a lot of shit go down in my
life,
but I've never had this fucked up
anxiety and all.
I'm not sleeping and I'm having a hard
time getting full deep breaths.
All this shit.
Trash Strip clubs.
Uh,
yeah.
I definitely did strip clubs.
I hope it helps some but a little bit,
but it's like a little bridge.
Yeah.
Bridge to happiness.
But uh,
but the thing was,
is that I knew that I could probably hit
up somebody and get a pill,
take all that shit away.
And to me I thought that's a fucking
coward's way out.
That's not the way you do it because
going through this shit means something.
It's something that I need to do to be a
stronger,
better,
more well adjusted man.
Like I need to go through this and deal
with it because dealing with it is how
you make yourself better in the future
so you know,
you go through a cold instead of getting
the vaccine flu instead of getting
vaccinated,
so now your body knows how to adapt to
it,
so you go through depression and
figuring out how to solve it and not get
depressed again.
And I'm not saying that there aren't
people out there that,
that WHO's chemical balances for
whatever reason have gotten all twisted
up and they really do need help.
That's the real issue is when I knew
that,
but for me I could tell that wasn't the
case.
You know,
I was just fucking heartbroken.
Right?
That,
that's what it was and it was.
It was not really few fine.
Poor Josh Barnett on the inside.
Oh yeah.
This is never going to find her again,
by the way.
Yeah.
The idea is that,
you know,
it's not either or.
I think the
same thing.
Yeah,
he's cute and very funny,
but I don't think you'd ever be
together.
I just can't get over the fact that he
likes guns.
It's creepy and a little scary.
Somebody as smart as him shouldn't need
a gun to feel like a man,
be a man,
lose the gun to shoot loads in her.
Oh Man.
It's a blast.
Hide my guns in a hole in the backyard
and pretend kind of propaganda is fucked
up.
It's like,
you know,
I've,
I own quite a few firearms and most of
it for the collection of it,
like I'm a nerd,
you know,
and that's the people that inhabit all
those,
uh,
those evil gun shows,
fat,
balding,
social awkward.
They're just nerds,
nerds,
that people that buy all the assault
weapons that everyone wants to go on
about.
All these crazy solves all these crazy
capabilities.
Gun nerds,
nerds.
That's it.
That's who buys these fucking thinks is.
Those are the only people that can
afford them or have the interest to have
them.
Well,
that's not true because there's always
crazy.
It's such a huge amount of crazy people
that share them.
There is a small amount.
That's when people really don't
understand.
When it comes to the numbers of guns,
it's like there's like Pierce Morgan.
I thought he was going on this crazy
rant about,
oh,
you know,
America has this love affair with guns
and look where it's got us and look,
it's.
It's so dangerous.
Guns is doing it well.
Yeah.
The people,
first of all,
you got to think about how many people
are not doing it.
Okay.
Because there's so many armed
motherfuckers in this country.
It's amazing gun.
I don't walk around pulling guns on
people.
When you get on the highway and you see
a like a traffic accident,
it's amazing how few you find they are
God damn millions of cars flying,
going 60,
70 miles an hour all around each other,
all the time in each other and they
aren't hitting each other.
I mean,
what?
What we have to realize is that when
you're dealing with a society,
a complex society like what we have now,
complex,
credible numbers,
the number of people is absolutely
staggering.
You know what?
I read something recently,
like America itself is like the only
example of so many cultures and races
and mixing all the way that it does.
Like you go to Europe and it's like,
for the most part,
almost all countries are pretty much
homogeneous,
right?
With a few exceptions of experts and
people from other general,
like in America we said,
you know what?
No,
everybody of any kind at any religion of
any faith,
of any creative,
any color,
bring them all together and to take all
these different cultures,
some quite different,
you know,
when you,
let's say from a root culture to know
before becoming an American,
let's say early stages of American,
how even vast Irish could be from
Italian and how they're brought up and
um,
their upbringings.
I mean fuck,
I mean there's so many different and yet
we managed to put together this country
that has survived,
you know,
however many hundred so years as it has
and has done some pretty amazing things.
Yeah.
Without us trying to all murder each
other all the time.
I think there's some issues that we
definitely have to be addressed.
One of them is this antidepressant
thing,
and I'm not saying that people should
not be on it because I know people that
have been on it and it's helped them and
changed their life and saved their life.
He sure,
but maybe you shouldn't have a fucking
gun when you're on it because it seems
like
a lot of people that are on these things
and take guns.
That's where my problem is,
that that's not okay
listed as one of the things about next,
but probably because of a pharmaceutical
industry that,
and the,
you know,
under the guise of the whole patient
confidentiality.
Now they say in the,
in the statutes that,
you know,
they can,
your,
you cannot have a gun if you're a under
indictment,
uh,
for crime punishable by imprisonment,
a exceeding one year.
All these different things,
illegal,
alien,
agitated.
Now here's the one that's even similar
to being on antidepressants and all this
is who has been educated as a mental,
defective or has been committed to any
mental institution.
Okay?
That's where they commit you.
Right?
And so,
you know,
by the,
under the probably the laws of,
uh,
of medical confidence,
therefore it's like,
oh,
we can't just tell people,
this guy is all jacked up on like four
different antidepressants.
We can't just say,
oh,
well you can't have a firearm based on
that alone.
Where I think,
yeah,
actually we probably should.
In fact,
if it was really to be honest,
my,
my whole thing is I wish that there was
a way we had a,
uh,
a licensing system to get your firearm.
Just like you have to get a car.
Like you have to prove your,
you have to take competency tests,
you have to prove competency,
you have to improve understanding of the
mechanics of the firearm itself,
how it operates,
how to take it apart,
how to understand taking care of it,
how to operate it.
I agree on this thing safely.
And then then,
then once you've passed such a certain,
you know,
uh,
amount of testing,
then you can be given a card and then
you meet,
you know,
can go out there and buy a farm.
I really think that apps people are not,
but I also believe that that we as a
populace are so irresponsible,
even more so with our motor vehicles
that is not even funny,
that the how easy it is to get behind
the wheel of a 4,000
pound car and go out there and kill each
other is ridiculous and it's way too
easily available to anyone and people
love just creating the hot button topics
and it's easy to get people fired up
about something.
Has guns.
You don't need those,
but we need cars.
Great.
Well,
I've seen people say,
you know,
if you could get another,
you go,
you got to go hunting.
Get another fucking hobby.
I've actually seen people write that
down.
That's the answer I've seen.
People say,
Oh,
I wish that the animals were armed to
what you were saying all about licensing
and everything that all that's all well
and good,
but here's the problem.
That kid,
it was not as fucking gun.
No,
he went and legal.
It's illegal use of the guns,
which is also the case with the kids in
Columbine.
Illegal.
They murdered somebody,
installed them,
yes.
So you're always gonna have that problem
if those guns exist and also potentially
let's say that mother had gone through
all that training and,
and,
and in doing so locked her guns up.
Well,
you know,
you now you're going really far.
You trying to make someone a responsible
parent almost fucking of course.
But
is that when,
when people are forced to do something
through responsible means to actually
acquire the,
improve themselves capable of owning the
opportunity to be responsible like that.
And,
and trust me,
you know,
me talking about having government which
I already think is incredibly
irresponsible and does things for its
own reasons,
create more,
you know,
licensing,
I mean there's always a concern like,
okay,
well then they just decided that nobody
can ever pass and therefore no one can
ever have a gun regulatory
bodies that do their job.
I'm out of passion first.
For instance,
fish and game fish and game does a
pretty fucking good job,
but he spent the money is all from
hunting tags and you know,
and that that's what pays for
conservation efforts.
A lot of people don't understand that
that fishing game does a very good job
of managing the wildlife in this
country.
People,
one of the most efficient.
Yeah.
How the hunting tags or even re relegate
it out there to the populace is because
uh,
they've,
they've studied the heard the train and
all these different animals and how,
how they've been getting sick or how
healthy they are,
how many infants they've had and all
this,
and they calculate how many tags they
can allow to give out.
And then there's even for dose,
okay,
well you have to go into a lottery to
get a doe tag to go ahead and be able to
hunt a doe.
And so that's kind of that.
That whole figure has come up by,
by being on top of what's going on with
the animals.
Yeah.
It's knowledge.
It's based on people who are actually.
They're concerned about the environment,
right?
They're not trying to get.
No one's getting rich off of that.
It's all passionate hunters and they
want to conserve the environment under
his love,
the environment and some of the most
environmentally responsible and
important organization in the world are
full of basically.
Huh?
And there's a problem that people don't
understand when you advocate against
hunting is that,
well,
if you're not the top of the food chain,
that you better bring somebody in who's
going to do the dirty work because if
you don't,
you're going to have all these prey
animals.
They're going to be running rampant all
over the place.
You have to do something because there's
not enough food.
And the,
the idea that if you don't kill them,
they're just gonna be okay and peaceful
and live with us.
You're crazy.
They're going to slam into cars,
they're going to die of starvation and
you're going to have a Predator
population increase.
There's a responsibility as human beings
on this planet and our involvement in
this planet's ecosystem can manage that.
We have to,
we have to work on managing it.
And uh,
and that's the thing,
but I mean,
but I think it should be more difficult
to get a car.
I really,
I agree.
I mean it's like,
I agree,
it's 70.
Think of it as a right,
76,000
people were involved in fatal crashes.
Now they didn't die,
but that's 76,000
fucking people that.
How many of those could have been solved
by not texting.
Irresponsible bullshit.
Just,
you know,
it should be a lot more difficult to get
behind the wheel and I want that kind of
responsibility.
I would love to see that to,
for someone to own a firearm.
And then even besides that,
if you,
let's say you take all the guns away,
if we have people that are doped up or
fucking crazy or whatever and they're
going out,
let's say say the Batman guy just walked
into the theater with an ax and he
fucking nailed three people.
He just.
Three people die for no fucking good
reason,
right?
But the idea is it's not 33 because he
doesn't have guns.
He's not,
he's not wearing.
And I'm not going to give any examples
because I'm not that asshole like a lot
of the media.
Well,
where they'll sit there and say,
well,
Hey,
guess what?
This is how you made x,
Y,
Z or how you do this and give a fucking
information out there to people so they
can go out and some other Wacko can do
it,
but look,
I could sit here with you in private
until you at least three different ways.
I probably could've killed everybody in
that theater.
Yeah,
no,
there's way the more strategic about it
and the thing is why we got to solve the
problem of,
of our populace murdering the rest of
us.
Okay.
But you and it's America and it's a
total rare a thing as it is.
Like if you added up all the people that
out of how many we have in the,
in,
in America versus how many are are,
are coming under.
It's still.
I mean in as pure statistics game,
we're not.
It's not like it's still a fucking super
rare thing.
I'm sure there's a statistics person
that can tell you the likelihood of you
actually being involved in a shooting at
all in anywhere in America.
Well,
let's get down to the nitty gritty
because we only got a couple of minutes
left for you.
Turn into a pumpkin.
Three,
three hours were useless.
Um,
what,
what is the solution then?
I mean,
is it arming schools?
No.
Army.
No,
definitely not.
That's the thing.
It's an armed guard and that kind of
shit from happening.
I had a,
we had an armed guard at our school.
Like I,
I think there should at this point in A.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with an arm chair.
No,
but we had armed,
uh,
an arm.
Just a police officer.
Yeah.
We had an officer on our school and I
had a pretty gnarly school.
We didn't have shooting.
Well,
no,
I guess we did have a shooting girl got
shot in the face seven times by some
little Asian gangster kid.
Whoa.
But,
and then we had a girl got shot in,
but you know,
and that was fucking super tragic.
And uh,
you know,
the key to all of that also is that she
was hanging around all these bad fucking
dudes and these bad dudes were doing bad
shit.
And you know,
it's like if you.
It's not like they came down to just to
shoot anybody.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I don't think they didn't even come to
shoot her specifically and it's just
like a.
and then you know,
why do these kids want to live this
lifestyle where they're running around
shooting each other anyways,
what?
I mean it's just like fucked up parents
to live education,
whatever,
and then it ends up in this girl getting
shot and it's pointless.
But yeah,
we had an awesome solution that NRA
rhetoric about putting guards and I in
front of all these fucking schools,
like that doesn't change the problem.
What if we took all the guards that are
working for the dea,
have them guard the schools.
We killed two birds with which we just
put one of them in every school so that
you.
And maybe these people could not only
just be in the school of standing around
with a gun,
but maybe they could also be an
influence on people as far as like just
being like,
Hey,
guess what?
I'm here to defend you,
but I'm doing it as an upright fucking
citizen and this is why it's important.
Well,
that would be like a volunteer sort of a
militia type thing.
Is that what you mean?
Something like that.
Well,
he doesn't like that shit,
but even if it was regulated,
I'm cool with that.
I'm just saying that,
you know,
do one further.
My,
my,
my point where I'm getting to with this
is that it's not just the having an
armed guard.
Here's the thing that helps change this
from,
from people just blindly shooting each
other and whatever community.
We don't have any fucking community
anymore.
No one's responsible and when I say
responsible,
they're not just respond.
You know what?
Just responsible for yourself in a
community.
You keep an eye out,
hey,
you got some crazy fucking psycho kid.
Keep an eye on.
Let other people know.
Like,
Hey,
by the way,
tom is actually fucking weird right now
and we need to be aware of that so that
he,
you know,
everybody just work.
Everybody just wants a little mom's
house nowadays.
That's,
that's my example.
They just want a big hand to come over
and wash all their laundry,
do everything,
and they don't want to see or be a part
of the process and made all that happen
anymore.
I think that
random or sort of a big,
broad way community is definitely the
answer.
I think that what's going on now,
what we were talking about with Internet
trolls and people getting exposed and
realizing that anonymity is slowly
slipping away.
I think ultimately that's going to lead
to a bigger sense of community because
we're going to have repercussions for
actions and thoughts.
Homes are going to have access to each
other in a way that I don't think we've
ever had before.
I'm hoping that this is a stage of
humanity.
I think we are really involved in some
sort of a,
a more,
a metamorphosis,
uh,
growing and developing because of this
technology and because of this sort of
connection that people share with
people.
And I don't want to be live in society.
I don't want to overstate it,
but that's the feeling that I get from
people that benefit from this show on
the Internet.
That's the things that people benefit
from reading things and being exposed to
things and lectures and Ted talks and
shit that they really wouldn't have had,
that
we need to participate more.
You know,
it's one thing to listen.
It's another thing to to to listen to a
show and then stay in your own fucking
bubble and never participate in the rest
of your community.
You need to be a part of your community,
need to be to know your fellow man.
You need to know your fucking neighbor.
You need to know you.
The more you're a part of this,
now all of a sudden you're not just some
random drone that nobody knows or ever
know and now you're a human being that
the interacts with other human beings
and now you're forming this greater and
stronger bond that's gonna.
Look out for each other.
Yeah.
We have to sort of somehow or another
feel a need for that and as a society,
as a society,
figure out how to engineer that,
that sense of community again,
and I've been trying to get all my
friends to move on the same block,
but none of these motherfuckers are
willing to move out to my neighborhood.
We're going to have to buy a patch of
land and do it cult style.
But I really think that,
that,
you know,
wouldn't it be the best way to live is
to like have most of your friends like
in your neighborhood,
instead of being in some neighborhoods
shirt with strangers,
which is how most of us live.
Or even if we're in a neighborhood full
of strangers,
why don't we make the time to make them
not strangers?
It's fucking ass music.
Wife and a country dog.
Get Out of my driveway.
Fuck face.
I just moved into a new place and uh,
at some point,
once I get it all put together,
I want to hold an open house in my own
little area.
Like invite all my neighbors that come
by and fucking going to know how shit is
coming and stealing my shit.
Yeah.
Pancakes,
belt.
They're going to go out there and
fucking wander up and down the streets
looking at some good ideas.
Josh Barnett.
What'd you need to do is be a fucking
leader.
You need to go out there and start the
Josh Barnett School for how to be a
fucking man,
right?
Sorry.
The ripple in the water.
That.
That'd be the drop in the water.
That starts the ripples,
man.
That's the best thing anybody can do.
And it starts small,
but it gets bigger and it really does.
You start by exam.
It starts by what you're doing just by
being you.
Just by having a character.
Being a fucking man.
Starts Small and gets big like A.
I just found
out that you were in my favorite video
game.
Beautiful Academy.
I guess I'm the wrestler if you enroll
me up.
How,
how,
how'd you get connected?
This is your second category game too.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know.
You know,
they just fucking,
they'd.
Somebody dug me.
That was into the game and they put me
in it and not to mention there's a,
there's a game called no more heroes.
It was on the wheat and I think you can
buy it on the PS three now even.
And the main character looks like a
Johnny Knoxville.
But everything about the dude is based
on me.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And a about the idea of,
of this guy going out there and fighting
the,
finding some debt assassin on accident
and grabbing his weapon.
Now he becomes part of the assassin's
guild.
And so the thing is,
he's now number 10,
so he just starts fucking fighting them
all and killing them just to get to
number one,
play this game.
What is it?
Oh,
this is where you roll up all the junk.
And uh,
he made this big giant ball of yarn and
you're one of the characters.
I'm one of the characters you can,
you can roll up into this big ball of
fluff.
It's my favorite game of all time to.
It's weird that you're in it.
Simply amused.
He,
oh,
he's a musician.
Way Simpler than that.
That's one of the more complex aspects
of his life.
Powerful.
Josh Barnett,
thank you very much for joining us,
brother.
Always a pleasure.
Anytime you ever want to come on again
and taught.
I mean,
I don't think we really got to the
bottom of this because I don't think you
can,
but I know it's your insight,
especially as an intelligent guy and
you're allowed to fucking enjoy fighting
and guns and allowed to enjoy all these
things and you're not a bad guy.
You're not a fucking a blight on
society.
You're not a criminal.
You're not doing anything wrong.
And I think that needs to be represented
as well because in you don't throw out
the baby with the bathwater.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
freedom ain't free.
Okay?
It's not saying enough cliches.
It's guns aren't the problem.
It's just part of the US people with the
problem,
right?
Sure enough,
God bless you.
Whatever that means.
Jihad.
Alright.
Hello?
Salaam Aleikum.
What else can I say?
That's nice.
Josh Barnett.
Josh.
Yes.
Praise out and he's in.
Gentlemen,
praise and Josh Barnett on twitter.
That's B,
a r n e two t's.
Now each fuck just doesn't eat well.
Yeah,
but not at the end,
but we're constantly Barnetti.
I'm like,
no,
fuck that shit.
Oh God.
Could you imagine that?
It's too many letters.
I don't know.
Fucking manly man.
Like you.
You don't need that many letters of the
toughest.
Josh.
I know.
How about that?
I don't know any.
Josh is tougher than you did.
Toughest job you might be.
The toughest job on the planet are
toughest.
Joshua are out there.
Huh?
I think you might be the.
I think it's really safe to say we just
did a podcast with the toughest Joshua
on the planet earth about.
Honestly,
I can't think of another bank at that.
On a belt buckle.
Yeah,
that's my tree.
I don't know what the fuck that meant to
you to reference.
Like youtube reference to Joshua Tree.
Oh,
you.
Oh my God.
You are fucking Weirdo.
And go to the doctor.
Please go to the doctor.
My special available on Joe Rogan.net.
Five bucks.
He'd already fucked.
Great.
I love how great it was filmed.
Like the HD is fucking hardcore.
We used
the same guys.
Positive image.
You're talking about the one that I use
at.
Yeah.
You were there.
That was fucking hilarious.
The special out of.
Bring your name up.
Oh,
I didn't get out of the middle.
The eyes,
but I'll fucking kill that guy.
Fucking talk.
No fucking rapist.
I was doing a brock Lesnar rape joke and
brought in Josh Barnett just because he
was there.
He's in the audience.
It's called audience participation here
called ad libbing.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I add flavor to the stew based on the
circumstances,
but it's available by Joe Rogan.net.
It's fucking hilarious.
I was in stitches.
I was dying the whole time.
Thank you brother.
If that's not alive and everything about
it was hilarious.
I do what I can.
I tried my best.
Ladies and gentleman,
we have so many death metal kids that
love you.
You know that death metal.
Fuck good.
I'm happy people in the bands.
The do Johnny Davey from job for a
cowboy.
He fucking heard me on this thing.
He came up to me at the.
At,
at the.
At the show is like,
dude,
I just heard you on a podcast like,
Huh,
Rogan's deal.
And I'm like,
fuck you.
Oh you listen to that.
And my boy rob Duke's some accidents.
Huge Fan of yours.
Fuck.
He wants to even come on the show.
Powerful death metal will have been 11
and you will check out Josh Barnett in
the last.
You must because it will be history.
That will be the very last fight in the
history of these trading organization.
It is over after that.
It's a,
what is it?
January one.
January twelfth.
Oklahoma City Chess Ivonne showtime
energy arena in Oklahoma City.
And he will fight Nan door.
Guilty.
Eramo girl kill Amino Amino group.
Gets a type of horse.
This is how you spell it.
G U E L M
I n O.
is that it?
Yes.
Are you sure there's not more vowels?
No.
That's it.
A profit better and make them smile.
And you're the fucking man.
Dude.
Thanks for coming on.
And it was a very enjoyable conversation
and uh,
you got a lot of interesting points but
a lot of good shit man.
And it's good to have a dude like you
out there.
Man Represents smart people also beat
the fuck out of you.
Thanks to a ting.com
for sponsoring our podcast.
Go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com.
And you will save yourself $50 bucks off
any of their crafty android phones like
the galaxy s three or the Samsung note
to,
to.
They're the shit.
It's like a fucking tablet.
I get,
I get fucking screen envy every time I
see that thing.
I'm going to have to get it screened.
V that's it.
That's exactly what it's called in the
bush.
I'm thanks.
So [inaudible] dot com as well.
Use the codename Rogan at o n n I t and
save yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements aren't you?
Freaks.
We didn't even get a chance to talk
about junior dos Santos and Cain
Velasquez.
Not Talk about that junior.
Here's the deal.
Cane doesn't get his take down game
going with his distance on a striking
early on.
And Juniors dictating pace and distance
on unstopped and the takedown,
it's the only going to farms away.
He's going to take them out.
Uh,
I don't think he's going to one,
punch him again because he's not
normally,
he's not normally a one punch knockout
guy as you've seen,
but he,
his,
his head high accuracy is very high and
he'll,
he'll pick it apart if can,
can get his down game,
his timing
on,
on fighting junior to initiate and score
the takedown early on.
If he can get it,
go and be successful with it,
he can win that fight the APP.
No one's ever been able to do that.
It's an amazing thing about dosantos.
People are always so afraid of fighting
him on the feet problem.
You,
it's just like we talked about what
Croak theater wasn't going to take him
down if he wasn't getting in his face
and slugging them out.
And you know,
juniors got great feet,
which is tough,
but a cane can do it.
Came,
has enough.
If he,
if he's smart enough and if he can get
the right mindset,
uh,
he,
he can put,
he put on his back and once it starts
it,
it'll,
it can continue.
You can keep doing it right.
You can't,
you get that timing down and all of a
sudden you pick up on that,
that Shoulder Movement for that jab
comes and you fake out you overhand
right,
and then stop and you go right into the
take down or you,
you pull them forward with some strikes
and then he thinks it's some exchange
and boom,
you get them on it.
I think another interesting aspect of it
can be if cain could take him into the
fourth and fifth round because canes
known for his legendary Cardio,
he ain't gonna.
He's still not going to be successful
and less he gets that takedown.
Uh,
that timing down.
If he doesn't get that timing down,
no,
it won't even matter.
Powerful words from Josh Barnett.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that'll be the UFC this weekend,
the 29th of December,
which will be going on an mgm.
You fucks Cain Velasquez vs junior dos
Santos dose and it'll be happening live
on paper view.
All right,
we will be back on a Wednesday or
something.
Merry Christmas.
Happy Hanukkah and whatever crime.
Goofy Shit.
You fall off the.
We Love Ya.
And I was glad the world didn't end.
Oh,
thanks for coming out to the end of the
world show.
It's fucking fantastic.
Probably one of the greatest nights of
my life.
Thanks to honey,
honey,
Joe Diaz,
Doug's Dan hope it was,
uh,
it was,
an epic evening and,
uh,
we're just getting started.
Bitches will see you soon.